Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Du, ich habe gehört, die AfD ist Staatszersetzend.
Ja und Antidemokratisch und unsolidarisch und völkisch-national und empathielos
Dackel krawatte ich und rechtsextrem und Klimawandel leugnend und spaltend und reaktionär und rassistisch und Geschichtsrevisonistisch und menschenfeindlich und faschistisch und antiparlamentarisch und verlogen und fremdenfeindlich und
und rechtspopulistisch und Verschwörungstheoretisieren und spießig und nationalistisch und überflüssig und humorlos.
Aux
Lockboot Netzpolitik Nummer dreihundertneunundvierzig vom zehnten Juni zweitausendundzwanzig hinzuhalten Frank Corona. Weil das Thema jetzt schon wieder so ein bisschen Hintergrundgerät, aber so ist das.
Meinst du, meinst du, die Zeitrechnung wird jetzt ungeändert von AD in AC? Von Anu Domini in in andere Corona E oder oder Koroni oder wie heißt es denn? Arno Koroni.
AC, ja, warum nicht?
Jahre äh Jahre ist im Jahre der Phanemie. Ähm ja, verrückte Zeiten, nach wie vor, ne.
Ja. Und die Mopo hat's auf jeden Fall gerockt, so. Was die verrückten Zeiten betrifft.
Genau unser unser Info eine leichte kleine Hommage an die Hamburger Morgenpost mit ihrem heutigen Titel.
Der der so geil war, dass jeder erstmal gedacht hat, fake, das, das haben die nicht wirklich gebracht, oder? So, oh, nee, echt. Geil.
In Bezug auf das Urteil des Bundesverfassungsgerichtes, dass es Horst Seehofer in seiner Rolle als Innenminister,
untersagt die AfD als Staatszerse zu bezeichnen und ganz ehrlich, ganz vorsichtig, wahrscheinlich ist das
gut und richtig so. Ähm also ich kann's schon verstehen, dass man einem äh einem Teil der Exekutive eben untersagt, stark wertende Aussagen über Komponenten
der Legislative zu machen. Glaube, das Urteil ist schon halbwegs richtig so.
Schmerzhaft es ist und ähm das ändert ja nichts daran, dass Horst Seehofer das in seiner Kapazität als ähm,
Modelleisenbahner äh durchaus sagen kann und ähm wir alle in unserer Kapazität als Podcast in der ebenfalls.
Ansonsten gab's in, in Berlin, ich denke, das muss man ja auch, wenn wir, wenn wir auf Zeitrechnung Bezug nehmen, darf man was bei uns ja nie Kernthema ist, aber es war trotzdem auch mal hier anmerken müssen, dass.
Thema, also seid das, seid es das Thema Corona jetzt.
Gab und ist alle anderen Themen verdrängte, hat man sicher gefragt, okay, welches Thema wird es sein, was Corona vom Thron stößt.
Und ähm tja, wer hätte gedacht, dass das ausgerechnet hier auseinandersetzung.
Mit äh rassistischen Strukturen und Polizeigewalt ist, hätte ich auch nicht gedacht.
Na ja, hätte ich auch nicht gedacht.
Aber tatsächlich mal Thema, was auch so ein bisschen überfällig ist, ne?
Ja und vor allem wenn man,
Zurückblickt, dann ist ja mal ein bisschen einfacher, die Sachen zu erklären, ne? Kommt halt einiges zusammen. Da in den USA.
Und das Interessante ist, dass es dann eben auch gleich so globale Auswirkungen hat, ne? Also, man kann sich vorstellen, wäre es jetzt zu diesem Mord gekommen.
Vollkommen isoliert von der sonstigen Situation, ja,
dann wäre es unter Umständen wieder so ein weiteres Ding gewesen. Klar, es hat jetzt eine besondere Dramatik, dadurch
dass dieses Video da war, das einfach nochmal also bei, bei all der Ungerechtigkeit und und und Viesheit, die sich da einfach über Jahre schon immer abgespielt hat
war's halt nochmal extra fies. Trotzdem weiß ich nicht, ob es in irgendeiner Form den den Fresh holt, der öffentlichen Wahrnehmung überschritten hätte. Aber dadurch.
Auf das Risiko, dass du nun falsch verstanden werden könntest, möchte ich's nochmal kurz betonen, du möchtest also sagen, es war nicht, es ist
es ist nie vorhersehbar, wie groß ein Thema tatsächlich wird,
die Größe wie ein Thema in der Öffentlichkeit behandelt wird, nicht unbedingt mit seiner tatsächlichen Bedeutung korrigiert.
Richtig, genau, das, das wollte ich damit sagen und und und das ist, das ist aber sozusagen diese Wahrnehmung bekommen hat, wurde eben dadurch gefüttert, dass wir eben diese ganze Choronapanemie noch im Hintergrund haben, die ja gerade in den USA nochmal extra gezeigt hat
wie,
schlimm die schwarze Bevölkerung äh dran ist und zwar auf jeder Ebene, ne? Also dann kommt die Panemie und wer ist dann wiederum am wenigsten äh geschützt und am meisten betroffen, sind wieder überproportional die Schwarzen. Und dann,
das hat sich dann halt einfach alles so aufgeschaukelt, aber was ich bemerkenswert finde, ist, dass es dann eben jetzt auch dazu führt, dass sie jetzt in Brüssel anfangen, irgendwelche Statuen in Fluss zu schmeißen, von ehemaligen Sklavenhändlern.
Ja, was äh für mich nochmal besonders lustig war, weil ich war ja vor ein paar Jahren, habe ich aber ein halbes Jahr in Bristol,
gelebt und kann von daher vielleicht die Sache nochmal so ein Funken mehr,
einsortieren, einerseits ist das jetzt nicht nur so eine Statue, die da rumhängt, sondern die ganze Stadt ist voll von Erwähnung von diesem Typ
Ja, also es gibt da einen coolsten Plays und coolsten Street und einen coolsten Building und einen kurzen School und überall,
und ich hatte auch damals meine Kinder auf dieser coolsten School
ja, die natürlich jetzt auch diese ganze Debatte an der Bagger hat und jetzt rumeiert und so ein bisschen da äh doof dasteht und so und sich fragt, ob sie jetzt ihre Jahrhunderte lange, Tradition irgendwie übern Zaun werfen muss.
Aber dann eben auch zu diese geile Dreistigkeit äh Bristal muss man dazu wissen, ist halt auch eine der Liberalsten Städte,
in Großbritannien, ne? Also äh extrem.
Links, liberal, offen, Kunst, Kultur, Banksie, kommt aus Bristol, et cetera, also das das ist sozusagen ohnehin so ein besonderer Ort
und ähm von daher interessant zu sehen, dass von dort jetzt diese Schockwelle ausgeht, die es schon dazu geführt hat, dass weitere Statuen abmontiert werden, in London und so, ne? Also es ist crazy alles.
Also, was ich, was ich in, in all diesem Kontexten so ja wirklich, ja, auf eine Weise entlarvend finde, die ja kaum noch.
Also die waren ja teilweise auch gar nicht mehr glaubt, ist die Reaktion von Polizei und,
Politik auf diese Proteste. Wir haben ein
ich muss jetzt auch mache mal kurze Sternchen dran, weil das ist sehe ich hier auf Twitter und ich habe keine Anhaltspunkte gefunden, dass es sich dabei um eine Falschdarstellung handeln könnte. Aber es ist so unglaublich, dass ich's nicht ausschließen möchte. Und zwar wurde im
Palemen Square steht eine ähm ähm und unter den unter der hat jemand geschrieben,
und dann gab es von den äh von den konservativen.
Ein Fototermin, wo sie sich Abend abbilden lassen, wie sie dieses entfernen.
Beziehungsweise entfernt hatten.
Entfernt hatten und so getan haben, als hätten sie das getan, ja? Es gibt aber ein Bild von der Person, die ist tatsächlich entfernt hat und das ist ein Schwarzer, der halt dieses.
Machen durfte.
Card Make this shit.
Die sich hingestellt und haben so getan, als wenn sie das gewesen. Und auf der gelben Weste, die der Mann dabei trägt, ist ähm,
ähm ein, also ist ein Firmenlogo, wo irgendwie hinten auch noch draufsteht, Making Show the past. Und das ganz, das kann ja gar nicht sein.
Das hat sich gar nicht gesehen.
Das kann ja also ich.
Ich werde das ist so boah boah kann ja gar nicht sein, wenn also 'ne dann natürlich gleich dazu.
Die Fälle von Polizeigewalt bei den Demonstrationen, die jetzt hier irgendwie in Deutschland und in USA und in Großbritannien und in bei jedem Land sich wieder zeigen. Also das ist wirklich eine.
Das ist wirklich ein krasses Ding. Ähm womit wir auch ehrlich gesagt kurz bei beim ersten Feedback wären, wenn dir das Recht ist.
Ja, vielleicht nochmal äh noch im Anschluss an,
an diese ganze äh Auswirkung, die das hat, also auch in Belgien sind ja dann Staat dieser König Leopold, Ludwig, was jetzt nicht ganz genau, ja, also der da im Kongo äh wo ja Belgien primär aktiv war.
In der Region äh zu größeren Tötungen von äh schwarzen,
Einwohner äh beigetragen hat, auch der wird jetzt irgendwie,
demontiert. Und dann kommen halt so Sachen raus, also gerade in UK. Das habe ich jetzt erst vor kurzem zur Kenntnis genommen am Rahmen der ganzen Diskussion, ja? Wurde zweitausendfünfzehn wurde bekannt, dass dann,
endlich eine Zahlung, eine eine Zinszahlung des Staates endete, für Kredite, die sie aufgenommen haben damals,
um die Familien zu entschädigen, weil die Sklaverei dann eingestellt werden musste.
Weil der Druck zu groß war. Und weil der dann diese Familien ihr Eigentum genommen bekommen haben
haben sie dann sozusagen eine Entschädigungszahlung bekommen, die so hoch war, damals zwanzig Millionen Pfund, was ein damaligen Verhältnissen so chorona bekämpfungsetat war. Ja, das
und die Zinshallung liefen halt dann noch bis zweitausendfünfzehn. Unter anderem war dann halt auch die Familie von Mister Cameron äh dabei,
die da Geld bekommen haben. Und so. Also es ist das zieht einfach so, man merkt jetzt einfach, wie tief das dann doch überall äh drinsteckt.
Und von daher kann ich mir vorstellen, dass dass das alles noch eine Weile trägt. Also wir wissen alle, der ist schnell vorbei,
Aber er hält hier schon wirklich enorm lange an. So und jede, ich würde sagen, jeden, jeden Tag, den das zumindest in den USA noch ähm aktiv ist, kann dazu führen
dass da so ein äh ja da haben wir wieder so eine komische Verlaufskurve, ja? So so eine Expontialatie, das das ist dann sozusagen, wird immer immer wichtiger und wird dann,
noch mehr dazu führen, dass eben jetzt wirklich mal Änderungen eingeleitet werden. Ich sage nicht, danach wird alles gut sein, auf gar keinen Fall, aber
auf jeden Fall gibt's jetzt diesen der so diese sinusförmigen Bewegungen, die meiner Meinung nach eben alle Gesellschaften und in dem Fall jetzt auch die Weltgemeinschaft durchmacht, ja? Wir leiden ja die ganze Zeit, wie schlimm es alles ist und Trump und überhaupt,
Johnson und ganzen Idioten und Bolsonaro und so. Kann aber auch ganz gut sein, dass sie jetzt äh auch bald mal ordentlich weggefickt werden.
Dann wissen wir aber wofür die Panthemie gut war.
Die Hoffnung bleibt bestehen. Ich werde an dieser Stelle nochmal ganz kurz ein paar wichtige,
oder ein paar Dinge empfehlen, die ich in in diesem Kontext in den letzten Tagen so medial konsumiert habe,
und zwar ist das einmal der Podcast Deutschlandfunk der Tag vom war es jetzt Montag Rassismus made in Germany ist der täglich guck mal kurz von der veröffentlicht wurde.
Äh haben natürlich auf ihrer Webseite kein direktes Datum stehen, aber achter sechster, ja. Achter, sechster, der Tag vom achten sechsten. Das fand ich eine besonders gute ähm Aufarbeitung,
ähm da sind äh zwei Gäste dabei.
Einmal, oh je, Panayotis, Gavrilis, der ähm von Deutschland von Kaupfstadtstudio, bei den Demonstrationen war.
Und dann Steven an Palagan, der ähm.
Ja über Strukturellen Rassismus da spricht. Und ich würde gerne diesen Begriffstruktur sein, Rassismus, ich glaube, der ist wichtig
für uns alle in dieser Diskussion im Hinterkopf zu halten. Das heißt nicht, dass alle Personen glühende, rassisten sind
sondern, dass sich wie von magischer Hand ebenso Benachteiligung manifestieren. Und diese Benachteiligung, die kann eben jetzt,
dann doch niemand in Frage stellen, ne, wenn man sich anschaut, welche welche gesellschaftlichen Rollen Schwarze kommen und in welche nicht.
Und wenn sie in besondere Rollen kommen, dass es dann äh fast immer so eine ähm.
Herauskehrung, als das ist hier, aber jetzt ein besonderer Schwarzer ist, ne? Nicht wie die anderen, ja? Und also das sind natürlich diese diese unterschwelligen Rassismen, die,
denke ich, eine sehr große Rolle spielen und die und das denke ich würde ich nach der nach dieser wirklich für mich sehr eindrucksvollen Aufarbeitung ähm.
Eben versuchen wollen zu betonen, der Vorwurf ist hier nicht, dass,
alles irgendwie glühende Rassisten mit der Hakenkreuzflagge im Keller sind. Ne? Sondern, dass wir eben diese unterbewussten, sehr schmalen,
Tendenzen überall in der Gesellschaft haben und das kann wirklich niemand
in Frage stellen, außer äh Rainer Wendt, ne? Der Vorsitzende der deutschen Polizeigesellschaft, der ja ernsthaft noch behauptet, bei der Polizei gäbe es weniger Rassismus, als in der Bevölkerung. Was einfach so
Ich meine, das ist so lächerlich dieser Aussage. Das kann ja wirklich keine, also der kann's ja wirklich nur noch drüber lachen.
Allein, dass ähm
die deutsche Polizeigewerkschaft einhunderttausend Polizistinnen als Mitglieder hat, die ihn als ihren Vorsitzenden tolerieren, zeigt ja schon, dass es bei der Polizei ein Problem gibt. Rainer Wendt äh
Ne, Rainer Wendt äh gibt Interviews in in diesem AFD und Pegida-Magazin Kompakt
und kritisiert da die Machokultur junger Muslime, die fast zu den Grundbausteinen dieser Kultur gehören würde, ja? Also, das ist die Definition von ähm,
ne, Rassenideologie, wenn du von, wenn du schon von genetik anfängst zu reden und also ja, lächelt lächerlich und da,
da haben wir ein Problem, das müssen wir angehen und wer dieses Problem leugnet.
Ist ähm dann doch wirklich sehr weit da draußen und großer Teil dieses Problems. Und wer dieses Problem.
Feststellt, ist aber gleichzeitig nicht,
äh übersetzt das nicht in eine, in eine Anklage, Glühenden, Rassismus, gegen jede Polizeibeamte. Das ist, denke ich, das, was wir, was hier.
Wichtig ist für uns alle, in den,
in den in der kommenden Diskussion, in den Jahren und Jahrzehnten, die wir diesen ganzen Scheiß aufarbeiten müssen, das, was wir im Hinterkopf halten sollten. Und das fand ich, war in dieser Sendung sehr äh gut rübergebracht.
Ähm zum Thema Polizeigewalt und eigentlich auch zu jedem anderen Thema, ist natürlich John Oliver eine Empfehlung, aber das, was äh John Oliver jetzt zum Thema Polizei veröffentlicht hat, ist also so dermaßen ähm.
Großartig.
Ja, ich habe das jetzt mehrmals geguckt und habe mir, habe wir wirklich mit Bewunderungen äh mir das angeschaut, wie on point das alles ist.
Und dann äh ist ohnehin zu dem ganzen Thema ähm Rassismus in den USA.
Kurzer Hinweis noch, also John Oliver, du meinst, ne, seine,
seine wöchentliche äh Show und er ist auch der einzige, der es schafft, aus dieser ganzen Quarantäne äh heraus seine Sendung im Prinzip noch.
Genauso zu machen wie sonst auch. Also man merkt zwar schon, der Sitz woanders, aber er schafft es halt einfach genau denselben Style komplett beizubehalten während aller anderen sich irgendwie Casual
fläzen und äh nochmal als Anmerkung zu diesem Beitrag über Polizei, also nicht nur, dass er da jetzt irgendwie äh aufdeckt, so was da jetzt alles war, das haben wir ja irgendwie alles gesehen, sagen, erklärt halt wirk.
Wie sich das Ganze aus den Zeiten der Sklaverei Sch,
entwickelt hat und warum eben die
Welche Rolle die Polizei eigentlich von Anfang an äh da gespielt hat und eben bis heute auch noch spielt. Also da wirklich dieses Systemische,
der Vorwurf dieses des systemischen Rassismus, gerade den arbeitet er dabei wirklich sehr schön auf.
Und dann würde ich abschließend gerne noch äh ja alte Klassiker.
Empfehlen und zwar sind das die ich würde sagen echt bei zwanzig Jahre alten Stücke von zu dem Thema der,
ähm den Unterschied in der Behandlung zwischen.
Äh in der Behandlung von Weißen und Schwarzen durch die US-Polizei in sein mehreren Anekdoten über seinen Freund Chip,
erklärt. Ja und quasi sagt so, ne, was was passiert, wenn Chip etwas macht und was passiert, wenn wenn.
Ähm eher etwas macht oder schwarz etwas machen. Ähm Klassiker in meinen Augen, der ähm Rassismus
Kritik in den USA und ähm ja auch enorm witzig, ne? Zeigt eben auch, dass diese Themen, also oder witzig aufgearbeitet und klasse ähnlich witzig, wie jetzt dieses
diese Aktion von den von den Conservativs ist es natürlich eigentlich überhaupt nicht witzig aber entlarvend. Und das macht's macht's dann ja eben,
Ja, ihr wisst, was ich meine.
Wissen schon.
Zu dem Thema hatten wir auch ein Feedback, ähm beziehungsweise mehrfach das Feedback ähm von also auf Twitter habe ich das eralt, als persönliche E-Mail, als Kommentar von Enno, als E-Mail von Jan, ähm.
Äh und wie gesagt, an mehreren Stellen sind gemäß, ich zitiere jetzt Jan. Mein Linus, ich höre gerade die neue LMP-Folge. Am Anfang benutzt du das Wort Dunkelhäutig, um einen schwarzen Menschen zu beschreiben, dieses Wort hat ein kolonialen Hintergrund.
Und wird von vielen People of Color abgelehnt. Die Bezeichnung, die du suchst, ist einfach schwarz. Ähm.
Tut mir leid. Ähm ich denke man, ich hab's mir auch nachher nochmal angehört. Man merkt, dass er an verschiedenen Stellen auch nach Wortensuche und hier eben das falsche gefunden habe.
Ich habe das glaube ich ergibt sich auch.
Aus dem, was ich sage, nicht verletzend gemeint, aber es hat eben das Risiko oder die Eigenschaft, dass es für viele verletztend wirkt, dass ähm tut mir Leid und darauf werde ich.
In Zukunft achten. Vielen Dank, deshalb für den Hinweis.
Also warum tut es das.
Weil äh wie ich gerade oder wie ich gerade Jan zitierte, weil es den kolonialen Hintergrund hat und das ist eben quasi äh so eine Rothäute oder sowas, dass das,
eine als eine ablehnende Konventation hat oder so eine biologisierung oder sowas, ja und äh,
ich denke unabhängig davon können Bevölkerungsgruppen sich auch mit groß mit gutem Recht selber aussuchen, welche Begriffe sie für sich als angemessen und welche sie als abwertend.
Ja, ist bloß wirklich auch nicht einfach, da äh sich zurecht zu finden, was denn jetzt äh gerade aus welchen Gründen auch immer äh gerade abgelehnt wird, also auf der einen Seite ist farbig Problem, aber of Color ist dann wieder,
der Normalbegriff, also das sind einfach so auch Schwierigkeiten, die die ich mich auch immer wieder finde.
Genau, die habe ich auch, umso besser ist es, ja, wenn wir darauf hingewiesen werden und wenn uns der die gewünschten Bezeichnungen ähm,
selbst.
Ereilen. Oh, großartiges Ding von von David zu dem zu dem Ding, wo äh wo es über die Bezeichnungen ähm,
für äh homosexuelle und das Anwort für schwarze geht.
Ähm Details suche ich auch nochmal raus, weil er sich genau auch mit dieser Auseinandersetzung mit diesem Thema auseinandersetzt, ne? Warum,
äh warum er jemand anderes äh nicht als Fairget bezeichnen darf und so weiter. Und es hat eine sehr, wie es bei David üblich ist, eine eine äußerst äh geniale Pforante. Das suche ich nochmal raus,
beziehungsweise, dass es so kurz das können wir auch mal ganz kurz hier einspielen.
Aux
Dann
hatten wir ja in der letzten Sendung uns schon damit auseinandergesetzt, äh dass ich mal ein paar Falschdarstellungen in den Medien sitziert habe,
Rieso als Vorbild nehmt und ähm da hatten wir einmal diese Sache von Philipp.
Der hat auch noch eine ziemlich großartige ähm richtig Stellung vorgenommen, die ich wirklich wahnsinnig wahnsinnig gut finde. Und da können wir auch mal kurz reinhören.
Aux
Na da ist sehr schnelle Absolution erhalten.
Ne, ich, also ich wollte das vor allem mal hier ähm besonders hervorheben, als einen coolen Umgang mit einem mit einem mit einem Fehler, mit einer richtig Stellung, weil er hat ja in den letzten Sendung gesagt,
wurde ja von irgendwie siebenunddreißigtausend Leuten gesehen, bis es geschnitten wurde, ja und
diese Korrektur sehen natürlich jetzt mehr Leute, nämlich alle und gleichzeitig auch die, die halt zu den Abonnenten gehören oder äh und jeweils das zu Beginn sehen
und drittens, was ich halt daran cool finde, ist, man kann eben so eine Korrektur auch anbringen, ohne sich selbst ein Zacken aus der Krone zu brechen, ja? Und das, deswegen wollte ich das nochmal hier als
echt cooles Beispiel fürn fürn coolen Umgang echt äh voller Anerkennung ähm erwähnen. Fand ich wirklich,
super. Und ach so, genau und dann.
Eigentlich gesagt.
Ja, ganz kurz, ich muss noch eine Sache zu dem YouTube-Kram kriegen. Da waren wir nämlich auch ein Feedback bekommen, aber ich wieder was falsches gesagt. Ich habe gesagt, bei YouTube kann man einfach Videos austauschen,
mit einem Pro Account äh und ich habe ja selber keinen, der hat also ne, der Blinde von der Farbe geredet und wir wurden auch korrigiert, was man wohl kann, ist aus Videos etwas rausschneiden,
Also die Kürzen, du kannst aber nicht einfach ein komplett anderes hochladen.
Also mit diesem YouTube Editor, mit diesem YouTube-Studio, wo du dann quasi auf der Webseite rum fungieren kannst.
Vielleicht ist es das, ja, ich. Also ja, habe ich von was geredet, von dem ich keine Ahnung habe, offenbar ist es möglich, ein Video um Beanstandete Stellen zu schneiden, nicht aber ein Video vollständig durch ein anderes zu ersetzen.
Hatten uns auch mehrere drauf hingewiesen.
Ist bei anderen Plattformen auch anders, wenn wenn ihr eine Plattform haben wollt, wo sowas geht, dann zum Beispiel wie MEO oder so, da läuft das irgendwie anders als bei YouTube.
Oder selber haust, ne? Könnt ihr machen, was ihr wollt.
Wir, wenn man dann nicht zu erfolgreich ist.
So, dann hatten wir, äh, du hast gerade gesagt, ja, Fleischhauer. Ich hatte ja äh Jan Fleischhower ähm um richtig Stellung gebeten.
Der dich doch bestimmt gleich angerufen, oder?
Hm, habe mich sofort angerufen, ähm.
Hat sich persönlich bei mir entschuldigt, hat eine quasi auf dem Fokus äh geschrieben, wo die Feder drin sind. Nein, hat natürlich überhaupt nicht reagiert.
Das äh nur mal als kleinen Vergleich. Ich habe das ja,
angekündigt, ich habe auch die die E-Mail, die ich ihm geschickt habe, auch nochmal vertwittert und ihnen geetmenschend, weil es ja sehr gut sein kann, dass er vielleicht auf Twitter eher zu erreichen ist, als per E-Mail, aber ja, nee, da äh hat er sich.
Vornehmen zurückgehalten, würde ich äh mit nichts anderem habe ich gerechnet.
So, dann hatten wir eine Ausführliche Diskussion über meine Einschätzung des Verhaltens von Alexander Kekule. Da sind sehr viele Kommentare
zu ähm unter der letzten Sendung. Ich äh kann nur dazu einladen, sie zu lesen und sich da in der Diskussion zu beteiligen. Ich kann auf jeden Fall nicht alles hier wiedergeben,
Deswegen nehme ich kurz auszugsweise Punkte, die ich für wichtig fand, die sind aber teilweise auch von mehreren Leuten äh gemacht worden. Ähm,
zunächst einmal äh sagt ähm wie gesagt, Auszüge aus seinem Kommentar, da wäre einerseits die Mehrfach wiederholte Behauptung hätte in der Bild
gegen Drostensstudie geschossen. Das ist nachweislich falsch. Er hat weder wie von Linus behauptet, ein Interview dazu in der Bild gegeben. Noch hat er auch nur eine der Zeile dazu in der Bild geschrieben.
Stimmt. Ähm ist korrekt, ich habe ähm den,
das Argument machen wollen, dass diese Bildwelle geritten ist. Er hat aber sich weder in die Bild gewendet, noch ist er von ihr zitiert worden oder sonst was. Ich würde jetzt zwar sagen, dass,
das eigentlich nur noch schlimmer ist, weil er damit natürlich die Bildwelle in andere äh seriöse Medien getragen hat, aber das ist dann äh,
ein Teilnehmensstreitigkeiten.
Ähm Slati schreibt weiter, dass die Bild hingeht und Kikoli eigenmächtig zitiert, um diesen fingierten Streit der Birologen weiter anzuheizen. Äh hat dieselbe Qualität wie deine Zitate von Kekule aus tatsächlichen Interviews. Ähm.
Also mit anderen Worten, ja, wenn wenn die Bild ihnen benutzt, ähm ist das nicht unbedingt Schuld, würde ich im Detail anders sehen, aber ich denke, der,
äh man muss auf jeden Fall eben den Punkt geben, dass er sich nicht selber aktiv dort gemeldet hat.
Und dann, was ich sehr wichtig finde, äh wo auch in die richtige Richtung lenkt. Mehr Diskussion des eigentliches, eigentlich ein Problem
ja? Wie kriegen wir wieder vernünftigen Schulbetrieb in diesem Land hin? Das ist was hoffentlich am Ende dieses ganzen medial abgefeierten
Wissenschaftler, Hahnenkampfe steht und da sagt er ähm.
Ist Kekolis Position und die muss natürlich hier dann auch gewürdigt werden. Statt, wie in der Studie gefordert, Schul- und Kindergärten einfach nicht unbegrenzt zu öffnen, was.
In Absenz konkreter Vorschläge, wie man das geforderte begrenzenden umsetzen soll, eigentlich nur entweder als null Aussage oder als lass sie einfach zu interpretierbar ist, fordert Kekoli, den Betrieb wieder zu normalisieren
aber über regelmäßig durchgeführte Pooling Tests
der Klassen und Kita-Gruppeninfektion schnell zu entdecken und effektiv einzugrenzen. Und das äh muss natürlich dann auch hier betont werden, ist ein konstruktiver Beitrag.
Einen solchen habe ich Kikula abgesprochen.
Auch schon satte auch schon länger und äh tatsächlich gibt's ja jetzt auch erste Bewegungen in diese Richtung. Äh Ersparn hat ja jetzt angekündigt, da nochmal acht Milliarden auf Tests drauf zu schmeißen, inwiefern das dann halt Kitas und Schulen zugute kommt, muss man dann sehen.
Hoffe, dass vor allem auch erstmal Krankenhäuser von betroffen. Äh aber ist halt am Ende auch alles natürlich eine Geldfrage.
Es gab dann äh habe ich ja äh Herrn Kikuli für seinen ähm geringes
für seine geringe Publikationstätigkeit gescholten, auch dazu gab's äh noch längere Diskussionen. Da sehe ich aber in Anbetracht der Diskussion nicht unbedingt Grund meine Position zu ändern, ich
bin da tatsächlich Verfechter von Pablish Ohr Parish. Äh die ähm die Ansicht vertritt auch froh nie.
Ich zitiere, möchte als jemand, der in der medizinischen Forschung tätig ist, nochmal,
unterstützen, was Linus sagt. Kikuli ist Petifinition schon raus aus,
denn seine Position ist sicher und er hat vermutlich sogar Haus
Mittel für Material und so weiter. Das ist eine unfassbar wertvolle Position mit, kann man eben richtig smarten Leuten ermöglichen, langfristige Projekte und wichtige Gedanken ohne Ablenkung zu haben.
Aber das sagt er mir sogar selbst, dass er das nicht macht, sondern Firmenberät und sich auf Kosten von produktiven Wissenschaftlern im Fernsehen,
profiliert. Und diese Leute wird man bis zur Rente nicht los. Ähm Alex äh sagte dazu ähm.
Quasi kritisierte meine oder Märkte an, dass äh es nicht so ist, dass die Hauptaufgabe, der Professoren,
die Forschung sei, sondern wir haben in Deutschland eine Menge Profs, deren Hauptaufgabe, die Lehre ist, dafür gibt es sogar eine eigene Hochschulform, die Fachhochschule. Diese wurden ursprünglich als reine Lehranstalten konzipiert.
In meinem Bundesland haben Fachhochschulprofessorinnen das doppelte Lehrdepotat eines äh einer Universitätsprofessorin, Fachhochschulen leisten, keinen nennenswerten Beitrag zur Forschung in Deutschland und,
bekommen trotzdem W zwei Stellen, wie viele ihre Kollegen an den Universitäten. Ja, würde ich sagen, dann kann der Herr an einer Fachhochschule wechseln,
Aber ähm ich sehe, was äh Wissenschaft äh angeht, habe ich auch eine von der fundamentale Position.
Ja, offensichtlich,
Ich denke vor allem muss man halt jetzt sagen, also es hilft jetzt wenig dann auch alles gegeneinander auf zu äh rechnen, was ich.
Zu guter halten muss, ist, dass er eben auch einen Beitrag zur Öffentlichkeitskommunikation,
leistet einen anderen als das Christian Drosten tut und man muss nicht unbedingt immer mit einer Meinung sein mit ihm, aber ist halt trotzdem auch sehr viel wertvolles dabei. Finde ich einfach.
Und äh abschließend würde ich dazu noch sagen, ja, ich meine, wenn ich mich darüber aufrege, dass wir hier so ein äh Streit der Biologen in den Medien haben, ähm ich bin dann eben froh, wenn der auch wieder vorbei ist und insofern war sicherlich das, was ich dann
äh über Kekoli gesagt habe, nicht zuträglich einer Befriedung der Auseinandersetzung. Wenn gleich war
So und jetzt kommen wir.
Schön, dass du das letzte Wort hattest.
Kommen wir zum aktuellen Geschehen.
Die Corona waren App.
Soll nächste Woche kommen, haben wir auch in letzter Woche schon gesagt, haben wir, also, letzte Woche haben wir gesagt, sie sollen übernächste Woche kommen und sie sollen wohl jetzt nächste Woche kommen, also in der Kalenderwoche fünfundzwanzig werde ich mich nicht täusche.
Ja, ja, fünfundzwanzig.
So ist es.
Und ähm
das merke ich daran, dass ich also der CC wird jetzt wirklich zugeschüttet mit Anfragen dazu, ja, alle erwarten äh jetzt so, dass das große Daumen hoch Daumen runter von Seiten des CCC. Ähm wir haben
ich habe das hier im Podcast immer gesagt und wir haben das auch auf den Seiten des CC immer geschrieben, dass wir.
Kein Daumen hoch geben werden. Zu nichts, niemals. Dass wir aber einen Daumen runter geben, würden oder werden, wenn uns etwas nicht gefällt.
Und ähm,
bei allem, was sich jetzt schon sehe, wie die Medien sich warm laufen, wurde ich das hier nur nochmal ähm in Erinnerung rufen und äh ich denke, die Rolle des CC hat ja äh
primär auch äh darauf hingesteuert, dass es hier eine Open Source.
Entwicklung gibt und die App ist ja seit einiger Zeit Open Source, also sowohl die App, also iOS und Android.
Als auch die Serverkomponente, das Backend sind ja seit äh einigen, seit langer Zeit schon
Open Source, was bedeutet, die haben nicht nur das Endergebnis irgendwann mal Opens Horst gestellt, sondern man kann jetzt quasi grade dem Entwicklungsteam über die Schulter schauen bei der Entwicklung. Was auch,
Ding ist, ne? Also diese per PT Leute hatten relativ eindeutig, irgendwie so ein
eine Brunch Public, wo sie dann irgendwie einmal so ein.
Komm mitharten, ne? Und hier bei diesen Corona One-Apps, die haben im Prinzip, wenn ich das richtig sehe, scheint es mir so zu sein, dass die ohnehin auf Githa entwickelt haben,
und dann irgendwann einfach dieses Repo öffentlich gemacht haben. Das heißt, man sieht da jetzt auch wirklich vom ersten Kommit an alles.
Was auch ein Unterschied macht in der Transparenz und der in der Nahvollziehbarkeit der Entwicklung. Und ähm es wurden.
Auch verbesserungsvorschläge,
eingereicht oder beigetragen von der Community, insbesondere hat Alva Freude da etwas angemerkt ähm.
Ich versuche das mal einfach zu erklären,
dieses, dieses Backend speichert ja Daten, also Namentlich.
Es werden kurz hochgeladen, die werden dann in eine Datenbank geschrieben und wenn jetzt eine eine App vorbeikommt und sagt, sag mal bitte die Codes, die infiziert sind, dann werden die ja runtergeladen. Und das eine ist ein Schreiben der Zugriff. Das eine ist ein schreibender Zugriff, das andere ist ein Lesen da Zugriff.
Und ähm.
Es gibt jetzt das Risiko von beispielsweise, also Schwachstellen in diesen Lese oder Schreibzuggriffen.
Und um diesen, um dieses Risiko einzudämmen.
Ist es, empfehlenswerte Best Practist dafür zu sorgen, dass wenn Lesen auf die Datenbank zugegriffen wird, dafür eine, ein Nutzer-Account in der Datenbank genutzt wird,
der auch nur lesen darf. So das sollte jetzt irgendwie sich eine Schwachstelle in dem Lesezugriff befinden.
Eine Angreiferin oder ein Angreifer nicht aus diesem Kontext ausbrechen und vielleicht auch schreiben kann,
und bei einem schreibenden Zugriff quasi den äh den nur dann nur den Schreibzugriff Nutzer-Account zu verwenden, wenn,
auch wirklich in die Datenbank geschrieben werden muss. Und das ist äh ist super, äh ist absolut richtig und das hat er hier als Verbesserungsvorschlag eingebracht und dieser Verbesserungsvorschlag wurde auch von.
Anderen Personen, glaube ich, ziemlich zeitgleich äh auch eingebracht und auch umgesetzt, ja? Handelt sich dabei um eine, denke ich, Signifikante ähm Verbesserung der Sicherheit. Ähm,
man muss anmerken, dass es sich dabei jetzt nicht um eine Schwachstelle handelte, die sofort Exploda war, sondern eben um nur Umsetzung.
Des äh Principics of Lease Privilege und damit eigentlich so eine Hertungsmaßnahme und eine best Practice. Und ist doch äh ein,
schönes Beispiel, ja, dass äh sich diese Open Source Entwicklung, die hier stattfindet, ähm tatsächlich darin,
äußert, dass Kompetente Leute mit drauf schauen, dass wenn ihnen etwas auffällt, Verbesserungsvorschläge eingebracht werden und dass die dann auch umgesetzt werden, ja? Finde ich doch ähm.
Habe ich mich drüber gefreut.
Ja, es gab vor allem kurz nach dem Source Code Release auch diverse Leute, die halt äh Code Rivius gemacht haben. Es gab da irgendwie einen von der IOS äh genau Rody hat einen von der iOS-App macht, der wurde auch
relativ zeitnah äh umgesetzt, also soweit ich das gesehen habe, bin von zwei Tagen
Ähm das heißt, das ist auch wird sozusagen gar nicht als als unangemessene Kritik angesehen, sondern da äh freut man sich eher drüber, dass man eben auf bestimmte Sachen hingewiesen wird, nicht selten ist es ja auch so, dass Dinge dann auch.
Zwar jetzt so sind, aber es schon auch, ne? Ein Prozess ist und das durchaus auch so vorgesehen war,
Also Dinge sozusagen, was weiß ich, fehlende Tests und so weiter, dass die dann halt auch später noch nachgereicht werden, aber insgesamt ist das einfach ein sehr schöner
äh transparenter Prozess der Freude macht. Also es ist einfach, man sieht es wachsen, man man weiß auch, wie man ansprechen kann.
Ja, weil du ja nicht nur den Code siehst, also du siehst ja auch die Person.
Ja
Du hast da die Profile auf Gitter, kannst die Leute anschreiben, kannst du irgendwie da eine Kommunikation äh treten, kannst halt äh an die Debatten auch teilnehmen, wie etwas zu sein hat, ja? Und ja, so soll es eigentlich
sein.
Fabian Schersche hatte bei Heise auch noch einen ähm ein Coach eine Quellcoat-Analyse veröffentlicht. Das, ja, da zieht doch alles ganz gut aus.
Ähm jetzt habe ich noch so eine Meldung gelesen, du verfolgst Apple News wahrscheinlich noch mehr als ich. Apple plant offenbar jetzt auch eine eigene App.
Also es wurde berichtet, dass sie das erwogen haben. Ob sie das noch erwägen, ist unklar. Es gibt immer noch dieses,
äh von Beginn an als diese Spezifikation veröffentlicht wurde, stand da drin.
Und in einem späteren Release werden wir das ins System integrieren. Was das heißt, weiß.
Immer noch keiner. Es gibt verschiedene Vermutungen, was das bedeuten könnte. Es ist mittlerweile äh bekannt, dass Google und Apple halt an diesem spezifischen Problem des Romings arbeiten, also wie kriegt man quasi,
die.
Veröffentlichten Kies verschiedener Länder zusammen, sodass ich eben auch, wenn ich im Ausland bin oder im jemand aus dem Ausland hierher kommt.
Zwei aus einem Ausland in einem dritten Land sich treffen. Wie kommen da die Kies zueinander? Das ist so ein, so ein so ein Verteilungsproblem. Und wenn halt nicht,
alle Kies der ganzen Welt zusammengeschmissen werden, was dann wiederum andere Probleme mit sich bringen würde, Datenmengen et cetera, ähm muss man das halt in irgendeiner Form machen. Da gibt es definitiv einen Vorstoß von
Google und Apple,
da auch äh noch weitere Protokolle zu definieren und und und Systemstrukturen, das befindet sich gerade alles so in der, in der Diskussion und der Zwischenstand ist, glaube ich, dass zumindest das deutsche,
Projekt äh anstrebt, eher so eine erstmal eine EU-weite Lösung zu finden
Aber dazu muss ich natürlich erstmal innerhalb der EU das Auskäsen, weil wir haben halt immer noch Länder, die entweder noch gar nicht auf diesem Ep zuguckt sind oder wo man zumindest nicht weiß, was Phase ist und dann halt, sagen wir mal so
der der harte Kern, also wir haben ja jetzt Deutschland, Österreich, Schweiz, Italien.
Und die baldischen Länder im äh diesem dezentralen Modell. Die also theoretisch auch alle miteinander, die Schlüssel austauschen können. Aber wichtige Komponenten, wie halt.
Polen, Frankreich, sind halt noch nicht mit im Boot und ich vermute mal, dass sie das mittelfristig irgendwann mal müssen.
Aber na ja, ist halt Politik, ne? Die Rolle von Apple an der Stelle ist halt unklar, weil ich denke, die hätten halt durchaus ein Interesse dadran
das Problem eigentlich auch einfach mal weltweit zu lösen und rein technisch ist es eigentlich auch überhaupt gar kein Problem, ne? Die
die App selber ist das geringste Problem dabei. Das ist immer nur die Frage, wo liegt sie ihre Kies hin und wo kriegt sie die her? Die eigentliche Integration mit diesem Tests, also so dieses Absichern, dass da halt nicht Kies veröffentlicht werden, die eigentlich
gar keine positiven Tests waren. Das ist der kritische Punkt und ich denke, das ist auch der Grund, warum sie dann gesagt haben, na ja okay, wir überlassen mal diese Koordination
äh den einzelnen Ländern, ne? Der hätte.
Na ja, das ist jetzt eine sehr, es werde, hätten sie auch machen können, dass wir nur eine halben Arbeit gewesen, ja, also ähm,
und das ist, das sieht man ja jetzt auch in der, in der Deutschen Lage gerade, weil eine andere Feststellung ist, ja, also diese deutsche Corona-App,
ähm hat ja einen oder sieht einen voll digitalen Weg vor, wie du als Anwenderin von ich,
gehe mich, ich lasse mich jetzt testen, scanne einen QR-Code bis zu, ich bekomme eine Notification auf meinem Mobiltelefon,
über das Testergebnis und ich kann mich jetzt ähm ich kann jetzt die Entscheidung treffen, ob ich meine Kies hochlade oder nicht. Ein, einen voll digitalen Weg hast, mit eben unterschiedlichen ähm.
Maßnahmen zur Sicherstellung deiner,
ähm Pseudonymität oder Anonymität. Ja? Und Verhinderung der Verknüpfung von Daten. Das haben die eigentlich gebaut und jetzt jetzt scheitert es daran, dass die,
Labore nicht alle ausreichend Digitalisiert sind, dass sie dieses Verfahren, der ja, digitalen
digitalen anonymen Zugänglichmachungen der Testergebnisse auch tatsächlich unterstützen. Es war auch von vornherein, das hat man in dem in der ersten,
Veröffentlichung der Dokumentation gesehen, dass es da diese Teletannen gibt
Ne, also für den Fall, dass du dann irgendwie telefonieren musst. Und da werden jetzt Hotlines für eingerichtet und die Hotlines muss jemand betreiben. Und da muss irgendwie sichergestellt werden, dass dieses System nicht getreut wird. Und das ist alles, ja, ich hatte das auch schon vor allen Dingen vor mir. Das ist halt Heavy Lifting, ne? Und das musste, das ist das kannste dann am Ende nur,
engster Koordination mit den Gesundheitsbehörden eines Landes und die in Anpassung an deren digitale.
Eine an deren digitalen Entwicklung stand, ja,
ob du jetzt im digitalen Entwicklungsland wie Deutschland bist oder vielleicht auch in der Digitalisierung in den in einem Land mit einer digitalen Infrastruktur, ne? Das macht ja riesige Unterschiede dafür.
Genau und deswegen
halte ich es immer noch für möglich, dass äh Google und Apple da irgendwann auch mal sagen, okay, für alle anderen Länder, die sich jetzt hier nicht so teuren Entwicklungsprozess leisten können und die nicht mal eben so ein
äh Softwaregiganten da am Start haben, der da mal eben so ein Team aus dem nichts hervorziehen kann, stellen wir einfach diese App bereit und auch vielleicht ein gewisses Backend, wo dann in Anführungsstrichen nur noch die Anbindung an Labore äh realisiert werden muss
ja? Und ich meine, tatsächlich ist es ja so, dass du in afrikanischen Ländern teilweise eine sehr viel bessere.
Anbindung hast, weil dir dort ein gewisser Hinsicht die ganze Wirtschaft auf der Digitalisierung basiert, also vor allem das Telefonnetz ist. Und ähm,
Das zeichnet sich noch nicht unbedingt ab, aber ich halte das nach wie vor für möglich.
Nur vorsichtig anmerken
wenn ich das richtig sehe, die ähm Lizenz, der jetzt SAP, deutsche Telekomentwicklung, Corona waren App, würde ebenfalls eine Anpassung und Verwendung des äh Socce Kurz in anderen Start
Staatsgefühlen ähm erlauben.
Ja, sicherlich, klar, ne? Al.
Unbedingt von Apple kommen kann könnt auch.
Ja und das äh war so ein bisschen unten runtergefallen ist, auch die Italiener haben ja auch so ein Open-Source-Projekt äh Prozess gemacht. Also diese Immuni App, die ist schon draußen und der Sourcecode liegt auch aufgeht ab.
Also äh da gibt's verschiedenste, die man nehmen könnte. Also es gibt keinen Mangel an Software, klar, den kann man nehmen, aber der muss ja auch betrieben werden, et cetera und es muss in gewisser Hinsicht da eine Anpassung äh gemacht werden, ne? Also, ich glaube, das ist so,
eine fortwährende Abwägung, die bei
Apple und Google gemacht werden, die immer so zwischen, was können wir eigentlich am besten machen und wodurch geht es am schnellsten, wenn wir das übernehmen? Versus ein, wo mischen wir uns in die politische Diskussion zu sehr ein und erzeugen noch mehr Probleme
als wir beheben können. Das da glaube ich geht das die ganze Zeit
hin und her und äh sie wissen, dass sie da vorsichtig sein müssen. Das haben wir ja hier auch schon ausführlich diskutiert und das sieht man ja auch an diesem ganzen Feedback, wo halt alle möglichen äh Vorwürfe erhoben werden, ob sie dann stichhaltig sind oder nicht. Und in diesem Bereich
bewegen sie sich dann eben, ne? Jetzt müssen wir erstmal schauen, wie viele Länder überhaupt bereit sind, jetzt mittelfristig auf das dezentrale Modell mit aufzuspringen, weil es ist,
eigentlich das einzig sinnvolle, ja? Also, dass Frankreich da immer noch nicht die Kurve gekriegt hat, finde ich,
eine Frechheit, ja? Also das ist einfach.
Was heißt der Free? Ist einfach also ich kann es, ich hab wir haben's ja hier oft genug betont, es geht auch nicht anders, ja. Äh es geht nicht anders, Punkt.
Und äh mit das ist nicht 'ne Frechheit, das ist einfach 'ne dumme sich dieser technischen Realität nicht auszusetzen. Übrigens,
ähm wichtiger Punkt, den wir den ich hier ich glaub vor ein oder zwei Sendung auch nochmal angemerkt hatte, war was machen wir mit,
Ja, weil die Google Play Services unter Umständen nicht auf die Geräte pushen können. Hat jetzt auch.
Für ihre Geräte dieses Protokoll umgesetzt und implementiert und die sind dann eben auch,
Google und Apple, kompatibel mit dem, was sie machen. Das heißt, dieser dieser verbleibende Marktanteil,
zweistellige Marktanteil von Geräten, die unter irgendwelchen Saktionen liegen oder so, die haben
für die ist das Problem jetzt auch gelöst. Und damit hat sich die Sache jetzt wirklich auch einfach mal geklärt. Also ich ich sehe da gar keinen Anlass, mich jetzt noch weiter damit darüber zu ärgern, oder überhaupt damit auseinanderzusetzen. Äh dass irgendwelche Staaten
weiterhin die Realität negieren. Das ist, macht Donald Trump auch. Da kann man mal kurz.
Zeigen, guck mal hier, ne, mir geht die Realität und dann kann man mal gucken, wie das weitergeht mit der Realität und den.
Ja gut, das ist für dich nur in dem Moment ein Problem, wo du dann da hin willst. Du willst ja da gerne auch von profitieren.
Ja, jetzt muss also da würde ich, also ich weiß, dass dieses Roaming Problem ähm,
eines ist oder ein interessantes ist, ich sehe das, ich bewerte das aber nicht so groß wie du. Ähm für mich wäre es so, wenn ich nach Frankreich reise und es gibt dort nur eine zentrale App, dann kann ich mit meinem ähm.
Apple, Mobiltelefon, daran eh nicht teilnehmen. Punkt.
Das heißt, weißte und hätte würde ich jetzt mein Android-Telefon nehmen, könnte ich mich vielleicht dazu entscheiden, dieses ähm.
Diese Frankreich-App darauf zu installieren. Ähm oder ich könnte mich dagegen entscheiden. Anderer Punkt ist, ich verstehe auch, dass es ein Problem ist.
Was langfristig zu lösen wäre, wenn man jetzt in diesem Zeitraum, wo man Kies hochlädt, an verschiedenen Orten war. Ich sehe das aber auch.
Nicht als ein so großes Problem an, ähm,
dass ich's nicht lösen könnte, weil stellen wir uns vor, ich würde nun nach Italien reisen, hindert mich niemand daran, die italienische App auch zu installieren
und dann am Ende auch eine mit der italienischen App zu machen. Was mich daran hindert, ist, dass die italienische App, dass ich nicht den italienischen Prozess,
folgen kann. Diese äh meine Infektion zu beweisen. Ne, da müsste ich wahrscheinlich von irgendeinem Übersetzungsbüro, meine,
Diagnose übersetzen lassen und ein irgendein italienisches Amt schicken, um zu beweisen, dass ich tatsächlich ähm infiziert bin. Aber das sind Probleme, die werden dann, die werden die Leute schon im Griff kriegen und im Moment ist, ist die Reisetätigkeit tatsächlich noch
relativ eingeschränkt und jetzt wollen wir erstmal von mir aus nationale Apps haben und dann kann man das internationale.
Hoffentlich auch noch klären. Ja, aber ich würde trotzdem sagen, das sind ähm.
Ja, interessante Technologische Probleme, in die jetzt dummerweise von auch noch irgendwelchen politischen hineingefunkt wird und das stimme ich dir zu.
Das ist meistens nicht ganz so gut.
Eigentlich fast nie, ne?
Die nächste Diskussion, die wir ja jetzt an die Backe bekommen werden, ist dieses so äh wie viele Leute werden denn das jetzt eigentlich installieren, ne? Und wie viel werden sich dem enthalten? Und da steht ja dann auch mal diese Frage im Raum so,
ja ist es denn, wenn's nicht genug installieren überhaupt ja? Bringt es denn dann überhaupt was,
Und da gab's ja vor einiger Zeit schon so eine Studie, die sich das mal so angeschaut hat und mal so eine Analyse gemacht hat.
Die viel zitierte Science, du dir Studie um von dem Team, um Christopher.
Mhm. Genau.
Von Oxford Oxford Universität, ja, Oxford Münster.
Genau und die die fühlten sich etwas missverstanden und haben sich dazu jetzt auch nochmal äh konkret geäußert und nochmal betont, dass,
so ein bisschen die Konklusion, dieser Studie in den Medien dann doch etwas angekommen ist, weil das so ein bisschen die Botschaft gehabt hat, wenn nicht sechzig Prozent aller Leute mit dieser App rumlaufen, bringt's nichts.
Und weisen darauf hin, dass das halt nicht die Aussage war, die sie gemacht haben, sondern die Aussage, die sie gemacht haben war.
Wenn sechzig Prozent aller Leute mit dieser App arbeiten, könnte man damit die Pandemie komplett zum Stillstand bringen.
In Zusammenarbeit mit Contact Tracing.
Und sie gehen so lehnen sich sogar so weit aus dem Fenster, dass sie sagen, bin achtzig Prozent, das installieren, dann könnte man sogar nur mit dieser App.
Depandemie im Griff kriegen. Das waren zumindest so ihre Erkenntnisse. Heißt aber nicht, dass.
Der Einsatz einer App nicht auch hilfreich sein kann, wenn die Installationszahlen deutlich darunter liegen
Ne? Klar, ist logisch, ne, umso mehr das haben, umso äh sinnvoller ist das und äh der Nutzen steigt da auch quadratisch äh an, weil brauchst ja dann immer noch andere, mit denen du das verteilen kannst und so weiter
aber im Prinzip ist ja die App auch schon hilfreich in dem Moment, wo auch nur.
Einige Leute damit gefunden werden, die halt sonst nicht gefunden werden würden.
Genau der der Inhalt, der der Satz, den sie sagen ist, unsere Modelle zeigen, dass wir die Epidemie stoppen können, wenn sechzig Prozent der Bevölkerung die App nutzen,
mit geringeren Anteilen oder mit geringeren Zahlen von Nutzerinnen, schätzen wir immer noch eine Reduktion,
der Nummer der Fälle und Tode. Ja, also du es reicht nicht zum Stoppen, aber es reicht zu signifikanten Minderung und was ebenfalls außen vorgelassen ist, dass,
sie hier ja sagen das ist die Modellannahme, dass es nur die App gibt.
Wenn aber die App kombiniert wird mit anderen Maßnahmen, dann ist ist natürlich für die tatsächliche Kontrolle der Epidemie diese Kombination an Maßnahmen entscheidend.
Und das, äh, also ehrlich gesagt, ich war überrascht, dass die, dass das jetzt nochmal klargestellt werden musste, weil ich, zumindest, wir haben den Fehler, denke ich, sicherlich nicht gemacht, dass nicht so da.
Nee, aber das, das kam schon öfter äh rein und ich muss sagen, dass ich mir damals diese Studie gar nicht äh genau angeschaut hatte. Ich wusste, dass es da äh eine Aussage zu,
gab und habe das dann aber auch teilweise immer so erzählt bekommen. War aber, und das haben wir, glaube ich, auch von Anfang an getan, schon immer der Meinung, dass dass das sozusagen auch etwas bringt, wenn die Zahl geringer ist, ne? Auch wenn natürlich,
äh ist klar, so ist, umso mehr Leute es benutzen, umso besser ist es, aber das heißt nicht, dass es da irgendwo so in so ein Cut of Point gibt, unter dem dann alles äh Vergebens ist, ne? Insbesondere da sich ja jetzt auch aus der aktuellen.
Wissenschaftlichen Erkenntnislage zunehmenden Maße herausschält, dass wir vor allem,
eben diese Clusterbekämpfung in den Fokus nehmen müssen. Also, dass, dass man einfach sehr erfolgreich sein kann, in dem Moment
wo man ein Trainingssystem
in Place hat und das ist jetzt nicht nur das Digitale, sondern so generell, was halt Gesundheitsämter so machen, umso besser die sich eben auf Clusterausbrüche ähm stürzen können
umso besser, weil,
der die normale verbreitung des Virus nicht so ein Problem ist. Also mit normal meine ich jetzt so einer gibt's dem anderen weiter, weil dann verrückt das Ding irgendwie selber, aber vor allem ist es nicht exponentiell, sondern dieser
Eigentliche Urerwert sei er null, den man diesen Virus
versucht zuzuschreiben, ne, der irgendwo so vielleicht zwischen zwei und drei liegt. Das entsteht halt primär dadurch, dass es halt immer wieder zu diesen Superspretter Event äh
kommt. Und wenn man genau die besser einfangen kann, dann ist schon extrem viel geholfen,
bis hin zu dann, dann ist das so für sich genommen, sozusagen schon die Lösung. Und jede Maßnahme, die man als Gesellschaft ergreift, die das nochmal weiter einschränkt.
Die ist hilfreich und da gehören die Masken dazu, der gehört
äh eingeschränkten Maße, die Abstandsregelung dazu, da gehört vielleicht jetzt eben auch die Vermeidung von äh langen, aufhalten
äh aufenthalten in kleinen, trockenen Räumen über einen längeren Zeitraum in mit verschiedenen Personen dazu
aber da kann eben auch diese App dazugehören, als neues Werkzeug, was wir so noch nicht hatten,
wo wir alle auch nicht wissen, ob wir nicht nochmal gegen irgendwelche Wendel laufen, aber ist auf jeden Fall wert, auch das noch mit ins Rüstzock äh aufzunehmen. Es könnte sein, das könnte sein
dass wir da vielleicht auch einen Volltreffer mit landen und äh in der Lage sind hier weitere Zeit zu gewinnen, denn.
Auch das äh finde ich ja gerade sehr interessant. Es gibt ja durchaus auch Anhaltspunkte dafür, dass wir ähm,
dass der Virus sich eben jetzt auf eine Art und Weise,
entwickelt wurden die Bedrohungen nicht mehr so groß wird. Also wo die Krankheitsverläufe nicht mehr so krass werden. Und das äh ja, spielt dann alles mit rein und dann können wir vielleicht auch bald mal wieder Fußball gucken.
Was sich ja ganz geil f.
Das willst du dir angucken, was Union sich da kaputt tritt? Also, da bin ich, wäre ich ja froh, dass ich da nicht hin muss. Aber das ist ein anderes Thema. Ich muss noch.
Ich muss noch äh ich würde gerne abschließend nochmal eins sagen. Und zwar ähm weil du jetzt gerade auch schon wieder dich viel oder weil wir jetzt gerade wieder viel die,
Annahmen dazu diskutiert haben, ähm würde ich gerne nochmal kurz betonen, wo unsere Expertise liegt und wo sie nicht liegt, ja? Ähm.
Eben weil das vielleicht unsere letzte Sendung vor der Veröffentlichung dieser App ist, würde ich gerne nochmal abschließen, kurz äh etwas dazu sagen.
Ob diese App funktioniert oder nicht entscheiden andere.
Entscheidet erstens die Realität und die die klugen Gedanken dazu machen sich eben Menschen wie das Team um und äh von mir aus auch,
die Birologin und Epidemeologin in Deutschland. Ähm.
Um den Teil, um den wir uns Gedanken machen, als Netzpolitiker Chaos, Computerclub, als Hacker, als Aktivisten, ist, dass wir, wenn wir das Experiment schon starten und zu wenig wie möglich,
anderes Risiko eintreten und kaputt machen. Und das ist das, wofür wir in den letzten Monaten gekämpft haben.
Dass dieses Risiko minimiert wird durch unseren unser Einstehen für den dezentralen Ansatz, der wir jetzt hier geguckt, das ist jetzt auch bei drei Monate her, dass wir damit angefangen haben.
Äh durch unser einstehen für eine Transparenz, durch die äh Beteiligung von verschiedenen bekannten Netzaktivisten. Ich habe jetzt mal Alberfreude da nur als ein Beispiel rausgegriffen und
Das ist das, was äh unser Beitrag dazu ist und
unser Beitrag dazu war und mit dem Beitrag bin ich eigentlich ziemlich zufrieden. Und jetzt können wir,
sehen, ob die App ihren Beitrag.
Auch leistet, der ihr zugeschrieben wird, durch die Epidum demologinnen und Epidemiologen und wenn sie das nicht leistet, dann haben wir wenigstens uns nicht besonders schwer in den Fuß geschossen.
Und das ist doch eigentlich äh eine ganz schöne Perspektive oder nicht.
Ja. Danke, ja.
So. Dann würde ich äh zum nächsten Thema kommen. Ist aber nur ein kurzes. Ähm oder möchtest du auch noch ein letztes Wort zur App sagen? Nee, du wirst ja du hast mit Tim mit Tim hat sicherlich nicht das letzte Wohnzimmer gesagt. Daher bin ich ja da.
Ne, bestimmt nicht, äh nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, ich diskutiere das ja auch weiterhin auch im Detail ausfüllig äh in UKW, aber ja, wir werden das natürlich auch nochmal aufgreifen. Das war jetzt erstmal unser letztes Wort. Vorrelease vermutlich.
Ja. Ähm der Verfassungsschutz soll Staatstrojaner bekommen.
Eine äh nicht unbedingt Neues Thema.
Sondern das wurde schon vor einem Jahr von ähm André Meister und Anna Biselli auf Netzpolitik äh aufgegriffen, wo sie den Gesetzentwurf veröffentlicht haben zum.
Ähm
zur Änderung des Verfassungsschutzrechts, der Entwurf eines Gesetzes zur Harmonisierung des Verfassungsschutzrechts und wir wissen ja immer, wenn die Harmonisierung, wenn Harmonisierung angedroht wird, dann heißt das nichts besonders gutes. Ähm.
Diskutiert wurde, in dem Zusammenhang jetzt länger innerhalb der GroKo, ob der Verfassungsschutz
online Durchsuchung und oder QuellentKI bekommt. Nochmal die kurze Zusammenfassung oder die kurze und Erklärung des Unterschieds zwischen beiden Begriffen.
In beiden Fällen wird ein Trojaner auf dem,
Gerät angebracht, also eine Schadsoftware, die den Zugriff auf ähm andere Daten auf dem Gerät ermöglichen soll
Bei der Online-Durchsuchung würde dieser Zugriff voll umfassend erfolgen, also beispielsweise Zugriff
auf das Fotoarchiv, genauso wie was weiß ich Zugriff auf.
Eure ÖPNV und Fernverkehrsapps auf äh was weiß ich, auf euren Tick Tok Stream und so weiter,
Ähm bei der TK Ü, bei der QuellentKI würde dieser Zugriff beschränkt auf Kommunikationsmittel, also Messen, Messenger, unterschiedlicher Couleur
Ähm
und nur die Kommunikation. Dann fängt er noch die Diskussion an, ne? Ist das nur nach vorne gerichtet oder auch Retrokrates, ne, auf den Kommunikationsarchiv zugegriffen werden kann, E-Mails oder sonstiges, aber das ist die grobe ähm Unterscheidung.
Die wir auch einem Urteil des Bundes,
Verfassungsgerichts zu verdanken haben, aus dem, ich glaube, Jahr zweitausendneun, in dem eben das Grundrecht auf Integrität,
Informationsverarbeiten, da Systeme ähm entschieden wurde. Nee, das ist fast sogar noch länger her, dieses Urteil, oder? Jetzt muss ich jetzt äh,
Okay, lange her, lang ist es her,
in den Details könnt ihr mich dann gerne nochmal korrigieren. Aber das war der grobe äh der Gruppe zusammen. Ich glaube, seit zweitausendneun darf das BKA nämlich eine online Durchsuchung in Fällen von Terrorismus machen
und eine Quellen-TKÖ in Fällen schwerer Verbrechen. Dann kam irgendwann die Aufweichung, das war glaube ich zwanzig siebzehn. Da war ich auch nochmal als Sachverständiger im.
Rechtsausschuss des deutschen Bundestages habe mich dagegen ausgesprochen, das war nämlich die Aufweitung des
Staatstrojaner Einsatzes für die Alltagskriminalität vor, also nicht mehr schwere Verbrechen, Voraussetzungen dafür sind, dass dieses Instrument genutzt werden kann, sondern auch,
ja, Alltagskriminalität, Alltagskriminalität, also etwas, was erstens sehr viel öfter passiert. Und zweitens etwas ist dessen man Menschen sehr viel schneller verdächtigt. Und äh was dann natürlich auch bedeutet, dass äh dieses Instrument.
Mehr eingesetzt wird. Nun also nach über einem Jahr Diskussion des Verfassungsschutzänderungsgesetzentwurfs äh die Einigung.
Das Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz soll.
Die QuellentKI bekommen und es wird nun einerseits gefeiert, das ist nicht die Online Durchsuchung bekommt und andererseits von mir kritisiert, dass es überhaupt dieses Recht bekommt und ähm da denke ich, möchte ich zu sagen,
das Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz ist nun wirklich eine katastrophale Behörde Gebäude von Skandalen, ne? Wir dürfen nicht vergessen, der letzte,
ähm Direktor vor Hans-Georg Maaßen ist im,
äh Rahmen dieser ganzen Skandale um den Nationalsozialistischen Untergrund und das Aktenschreddern und was da nicht alles war äh gegangen. Ja, also das war quasi wegen der Nähe zu den.
Zu den rechten,
und rechtsradikalen Bestrebungen in unserer Gesellschaft musste da schon jemand den Hut nehmen und der ne der Vertuschung von,
zusammenarbeiten, Koaper, Kooperation und sonstigen. Ersetzt wurde er dann durch ein rechtsextrem Verschwörungstheoretiker, ja? In dem Fall Hans Georg Maaßen.
Der.
Jetzt inzwischen, also wenn ich habe mir ab und zu gucke ich mir mal den Twitter-Feed von dem an und ich kann verwende, dass er diese Formulierung geht und doch öfter, als ich meine, aber eigentlich meine ich selten, da gefriert dir echt
das Blut in den Adern, wenn du liest, was der Typ von sich gibt und jetzt so gerade gerade, ja, also.
Und und und du hast dann noch die ganzen Geheimdienstskandale ohnehinoten, ja? Und in dieser Zeit geht man jetzt hin und sagt, ey jo, hör mal, den könnten wir eigentlich äh beim Staatstojaner noch geben.
Und du kannst dir ungefähr vorstellen, in welche Richtung dieser Staatstrojaner dann schießt, ja? Ich kann euch nur dazu einladen, bitte macht das bei Leuten vom CC. Wir interessieren uns sehr für diese Staatstrojaner. Das wisst ihr, ähm Thorsten und ich hatten ja ähm,
im Dezember dazu noch was produziert zu Finnfischer und das ist natürlich genau
eines der wenigen Unternehmen, bei denen die dann einkaufen können, ne? Die landen am Ende bei NSO Group oder bei Finn Fischer und kaufen sich dort so ein Produkt, ein Produkt, was von Dispoten äh auf diesen
Planeten gegen Disidentinnen und Distidenten eingesetzt wird und das ist mit Sicherheit keine positive Entwicklung, was wir.
Von führenden Diktatoren empfohlen. Äh hat mir nicht so weit sonst ein Sendungstitel schon mal.
Hatten wir auch schon, ja.
Ja, das gilt nach wie vor.
Allerdings schauen wir mal, das ist die die Nachricht war jetzt nur, dass es eine Einigung gibt.
Zwischen SPD und CDU. Jetzt sind wir mal gespannt ähm wie.
Das weitergeht, ich gehe davon aus, dass dieses äh Gesetz nochmal in den Ausschüssen des Deutschen Bundestags diskutiert wird und bin sehr gerne bereit dazu nochmal eine Stellungnahme zu formulieren.
Bis schön.
Kann ich im Zweifelsfall unsere Halten nehmen, gibt ja keine neuen Argumente. Okay, lassen wir das.
Gut, machen wir äh weiter mit einer äh Nachricht, von der ich mal ganz frech behaupten würde, dass es sich dabei um eine gute Nachricht handelt.
Aux
Weil sonst haben wir ja nicht so viel und ähm.
Hier äh geht's mal wieder um Wissenschaft, das ist ja irgendwie gerade auch der heiße Scheiß, ne? So wissenschaftliche Studien äh vom Internet runter puppeln und dann mal so gucken, was da so drinsteht
weiß nicht, das hat enorm an Popularität gewonnen. Jetzt gab es eine Studie, die natürlich, wie das sich so gehört, bisher nur als,
verfügbar ist. Also sozusagen noch der äh standhalten muss. Die aber nichtsdestotrotz ganz interessant ist, denn sie
setzt sich auseinander mit der Problematik der Hassrede im Internet.
Und äh ja, das haben wir ja nun hier auch schon oft auf aus verschiedenen Positionen heraus.
Ähm beleuchtet und vor allem schwitt nur all dem immer wieder so diese Problematik, dass man nicht so recht weiß, was man jetzt eigentlich am besten,
dagegen tut, ja, wie
kämpft man dieses Phänomen, dass sich Leute in den letzten auf gegenseitig aufschaukeln und dann bis hin zu den Absurdisten Verschwörungsebenen hochschrauben und irgendwie auch.
Nicht mehr in der Lage sind, äh einen normalen Diskurs zu führen, ne? Und dass ja auch diese ganze Diskurs Zerstörung teilweise von dritten
auch nochmal bewusst befeuert wird, äh so, ne? Staatszersetzend kann man an der Stelle vielleicht auch nochmal hervorkramen.
Und ja, es gibt ja allerlei Möglichkeiten.
Wie man da vorgehen könnte, man kann Dinge verbieten, das funktioniert äh nur so beschränkt, man kann äh umfangreiche Zensur und Rücknahme äh Methoden empfehlen oder äh Gebieten und Durchsetzen
hat alles so seine Vor und seine Nachteile.
Und was ja auch noch ein möglicher Ansatz ist, ist so das, was so dann ähm immer so diese.
Besonders hoffnungsfrohen optimistischen Menschen sagen, so ja, ne. Da müssen wir einfach mal drüber reden. Da sitzen wir uns hin. Da machen wir uns einen Tee.
Und dann rede ich mit den Leuten. Und die anderen ah nee, mit Nazis kann man nicht reden und so und das funktioniert alles nicht und dann kannst du eh nicht überzeugen. Tja.
Und was jetzt stimmt ist nach wie vor offen,
Kommen wir zu dieser Studie? Diese Studie hat was ganz interessantes gemacht. Also es ist ein Team USA, die haben aber mindestens einen Mitglied davon, hat irgendwie in Deutschland Bezug,
und die haben jetzt so gesagt, okay, wir wir schauen mal, ob wir nicht in irgendeiner Form analysieren können, wie sich.
Ein Diskurs im Internet so verhält, wenn Leute anfangen hier einfach mit
Argumenten äh an vielleicht mit einer vernünftigen Grundhaltung daher zu kommen, äh um sozusagen eine Hassrede etwas entgegenzustellen.
Und hier kam natürlich, wie sollte es auch anders sein? Machine Learning, zum Einsatz konkret wurde hier so ein.
Ensemble, Algorithmen äh angewendet, kannte den Begriff noch nicht, sagt dir das was eigentlich konkret Minus?
Okay.
Ja, kannte ich auch noch nicht und ähm ist halt auf einfach eine Technik aus dem Learning, mit der man eben so einen Lernverhalten äh modellieren kann. Und dazu haben sie sich dann neun Millionen Tweets.
Geholt und zwar nicht irgendwelche Tweets, sie haben ein
ein Sonderfall in der Internetgeschichte genommen und das ist dann die Auseinandersetzung zwischen der Trollarmee Rekong, Quizta Germanica und der Bömmermann Armee Ricon Quista,
Internet, die ja zweitausendachtzehn angefangen hat, zu sagen, so, oh,
hier die wollen uns trollen, wir treuen zurück und äh versuchen hier mal einen Diskurs zu starten.
Und das besondere daran war, dass diese beiden Gruppen im Netz relativ leicht
zu sehen waren. Also sie haben in der Studie wird von Self Labeling gesprochen, hat also hier relativ gut ausmachen können, wer quasi Vertreter der einen Seite und Vertreter der anderen Seite ist und vor allem waren sie
direkt miteinander in Bezug, ja? Also die auf der einen Seite und die Anti-Troller mehr auf der anderen Seite
die haben sich halt dann mal wirklich über längere Zeit so einen Stellungskrieg geliefert,
und dabei ebenso ihre Waffen ausgepackt, also Hass, Beschimpfungen, behaup
Dorn et cetera auf der einen Seite und äh ebenso dieses Jahr nee, kann man nicht so sehen und hier äh schau dir doch mal dieses Argument an und man könnte ja es vielleicht auch nochmal anders darstellen, auf der anderen Seite.
Und damit haben sie ihr Maschinenlearning-Modell trainiert
und dann äh quasi Algorithmen gewonnen, mit denen sie sagen können, okay, meiner Meinung nach,
handelte sich bei diesem Tweet um einen gemäßigten Kommentar. Hier handelt es sich um ein weniger gemäßigten Kommentar und validiert haben sie das durch so ein. Also wir haben halt dann
quasi dieses Modell trainiert, über Twits Aussagen gemacht und dann diese Aussage dann eben nochmal manuell über,
dem halt Leute gesagt haben, so ja, okay, das sehe ich aber auch so. So ein bisschen, so wie diese Captures wurde immer irgendwelche Ampeln und äh amerikanischen,
Schull, Busse markieren muss. So, das ist ja soll ja gar nicht so sehr beweisen, dass du ein Mensch bist, äh damit willst du ja soll es ja Google helfen, dass ihre Algorithmen stimmen,
So, ne. Billiger Arbeit. Ja und ähm,
Dann hatten sie dieses Modell und haben sich dann wiederum äh Konversationen auf Twitter, Twitter über längeren Zeitraum angeschaut, also hier ist von einhundertdreißig oder hundertfünfunddreißigtausend Conversationen auf Twitter die Rede
die so zwischen zwanzig, dreizehn und zwanzig achtzehn stattgefunden haben, wo dann eben.
Mit diesem Modell und ich vermute mal, dass es sich dann auch um deutsche Tweets handelt. Also sie haben sozusagen den ganzen Internet, Twitter-Diskurs Deutschland über einen Zeitraum von sechs Jahren angeschaut, um rauszufinden
welchen Einfluss jetzt gegen Rede auf Hassredelnen tatsächlich hat.
Und stellt sich raus, Kongulusion in diesem Payper äh ist äh unsere Ergebnisse deuten daraufhin, dass die Gegenrede zur Depolarisierung der Diskussion Beitrug.
Und dass die von Reconquista Internet organisierte Gegenrede weitere Gegenrede anregt.
Und weniger hasserfüllte Reaktionen hervorgerufen haben könnte,
eine organisierte Gegenrede da könnte daher eine Wirkungsvolle Lösung zur Bekämpfung der Verbreitung von Hass im Internet sein. Wir hoffen, dass das in diesem Papier entwickelte Rahmenwerk.
Ein Ausgangspunkt für das Verständnis der Dynamik zwischen Hass und Gegenrede ist und dazu beiträgt handlungsfähige Strategien zu entwickeln.
Und das Maschinenlearning hier an dieser Stelle auch helfen kann, habe ich jetzt bewiesen,
indem ich nämlich diese Konklusion aus dem englischen Payper einfach ein Depell reingeworfen habe, um diese Übers.
Vorgelesen habe zu der Zeug und ich bin selber beeindruckt davon wie und das ist ja nichts nachgearbeitet. Also das funktioniert langsam der Scheiß,
und.
Was sagt man dazu? Man sagt, die Studie belegt erstmal empirisch, was wir mit Rico und Quizzer Internet
erfahren haben, wir organisierten Hass, rassistische Hetze oder die cleveren Diskursverschiebungen, Kampagnen, Rechtsextremistischer Netzwerke im Internet erfolgreich bekämpfen will.
Muss wissen, wie diese verdeckten Manipulationsnetzwerke arbeiten, sie analysieren und gegen sie aktiv werden.
Ja. Also das äh.
Finde ich ist irgendwie eine also gute Nachricht vielleicht ein bisschen übertrieben, aber es verbreitet einen gewissen Optimismus, weil,
das sozusagen auch.
So ein bisschen diese These unterfüttert mit, es könnte sich vielleicht auch von alleine so wieder einen Norden, ne, auch wenn wir da vielleicht noch recht weit von entfernt sind.
Mal gucken.
Ja. Also ein ein äh ein Ergebnis, was den Eindruck macht, so schön zu sein, um wahr zu sein, aber äh.
Wie, wie sind denn deine Erfahrungen damit? Also, ich habe ja auch ab und zu mal so Twitter.
Im im Austausch mit Idioten oder.
Na ja, also mit sagen wir mal so, mit Vollidioten ist schwierig. Ja, und die denke ich.
Auch relativ schnell zu entdecken. Oft habe ich, ich hatte das jetzt gerade auch in den letzten Tagen wieder so ein bisschen habe ich so Leute, die wirken erhitzt.
Was, was ich meine? Also und zwar nicht so sehr erhitzt aus einem, ich will erhitzt sein und ich ähm.
Ich will jetzt auch andere erhitzen, was ich mal so ein bisschen mehr äh im Kontext tolle,
ja, die so ein Objekt der Farben, denen es darum geht und deswegen auch nicht überzeugen kannst. Aber dann gibt's halt Leute, die wurden erhitzt,
Die wurden erhitzt durch falsch verstandene, falsch,
gelesene, falsch informierte Quellen und.
Daraus hat sich dann sozusagen so eine, so eine Empörung, so eine so ein Teile zumindest auch breit gemacht,
die sie dann irgendwie auslegen. Ja, aber ist ja so und ist ja so und ist ja so. Und wenn das halt so Gebiete betrifft und nicht da auch gestreift werde in diesen Debatten, wo ich vielleicht auch mal wirklich konkret was zu sagen kann und wo das nicht so ein Thema ist, mit ja, könnte so sein, könnte so sein, sondern wo sich das eben mal wirklich anhand von belegbaren Fakt
auch entlang hangeln lässt, dann habe ich gemerkt, dass in dem Moment, wo man,
mit einer weniger erhitzten Grundstimmung, vor allem
und eben na klaren Orientierung, an so einer Faktenlage, wenn man dann sagt, so, ja, nee, ist aber nicht so, weil,
und hier und da und Quelle und dies und das. Durchaus diese diese Teilerhitzung wieder ein bisschen runtergefahren bekommt. Bis hin zu ah okay, ich sehe es jetzt anders. Also schon gesehen.
Also es ist ja äh ich denke.
Das das Entscheidende ist, das hier wurde ja eine Studie gemacht, genau weil die einzelne individuelle Erfahrung eben keinen grundsätzlichen Erkenntnisgewinn bringt, ja? Ähm.
Wenn also, was weiß ich, meine Erfahrung damit gut oder schlecht sind, mag das an der Qualität meines Herangehens sein. Äh liegen es mag an der äh an der Auswahl,
der Personen liegen, mit denen ich mich auseinandersetze und deswegen ist die individuelle Erfahrung eben immer
ähm Unsinn, ja. Ähm als jemand der Psychologie studiert hat äh und auch äh teilweise geleert hat, muss sich das sehr häufig sagen, ne? Also wenn du das immer so Leute, die sich ja in den Seminaren melden und sagen, ja, aber bei meiner Tante ist das andersrum,
Ne, denn nein, deine Tante ist jetzt nicht ein Wissenschaftlicher Spezialfall, der die allgemeine Validität der Aussage ähm.
In Zweifel stellt, sondern sie ist eben ein Beispiel dafür, dass man hier Aussagen über allgemeine Tendenzen macht. Ähm zweitens.
Annegdotische Evidenz.
Genau, diese dieses Beispiel mit dem ähm wie überzeuge ich Menschen von Fakten, ja, das ist ja jetzt auch nicht ein,
fällt, was in, sagen wir mal, Psychologie, Kommunikationswissenschaften, Soziologie nicht schon seit längerer Zeit erforscht.
Würde, ne? Ähm neu ist, denke ich, hier diese Sache.
In dem spezifischen Feld, der sogenannten sozialen Medien zu erforschen. Und,
da der ne, das ist ja hier der der entscheidende Punkt und ja, wie ist da, also ich denke, da da ist einfach Forschung notwendig, genau solche Studien und,
jetzt wäre der nächste Schritt ist.
Nachdem du eben erkannt hast, aha, so gegen Rede hilft, ist jetzt natürlich der nächste Punkt zu erforschen, welches sind denn die Bedingungen unter den Gegenrede hilft?
Ja? Welche Voraussetzungen äh müssen vielleicht die Rezeptinnen mitbringen, ähm welche Voraussetzungen,
müssen eventuell diejenigen mitbringen, die die gegen Rede anbringen und welche Eigenschaften muss die Gegenrede wiederum haben, um.
Erfolgreich zu sein. Und meistens hast du da dann ähm sowohl ähm sage ich mal Effekte, also per persönliche Effekte, wo man sagt, okay, was weiß ich, dem Tim gelingt es eher eine andere Person umzustimmen.
Oder Leuten wie Tim, die bestimmte Eigenschaften haben, gelingt es eher andere umzustimmen und dann geht's wiederum ähm quasi die Partnereffekte, Leute, die bestimmte Eigenschaften haben, sind einfacher,
Argumenten zugänglich als andere. Und dann gibt's nochmal die Interaktionseffekte, ne? Dann gibt's quasi diejenigen, die rational Argumentation zugänglich sind.
Sind einfacher von Tim umzustimmen, weil Tim rational argumentiert. Und ne, also das Partner-Effekt, Interaction Effect
Und diese quasi zu äh als nächstes jetzt zu untersuchen ist, denke ich mal, der Detail, wo es hingehen muss und da wird sich dann am Ende so eine Matrix rausgeben, wo du eben siehst, aha, du hast so und so viele Leute, den musst du auf diese Weise kommen, du hast so viele Leute, die musst du auf diese Weise kommen
und.
Du hast zwischen diesen Leuten Passungen, wer denen besser kommen kann und du hast einen verlorenen Rest, bei denen alle bei denen die Forschung.
Ans ans Ende ihres Rates kommt. Und ich denke klar, da muss man, da wird's jetzt nicht eine Antwort geben, ja? Also jetzt zu sagen, gegen Rede hilft, ähm
darf natürlich jetzt nicht auch dadurch interpretiert werden, dass dass man jetzt, ne, also eine sehr, sehr plumpe Interpretation wäre jetzt, dass man sagt, okay, wir müssen jetzt Wahrheit, Spots machen und ballern, damit die Leute zu, ne? Das wird sicherlich nicht.
So gut funktionieren. Ein ein schönes Beispiel, was es gerade gibt.
Auch das wieder etwas mit der Katze, weißt du nicht, ob du lachen oder weinen sollst, ne? Donald Trump hat ja diese Diskussion darüber angefragt, dass er dass jetzt die die Antifa.
Eine Terrorismusorganisation.
Werden müsse nach amerikanischer Auffassung. Wer sich ein bisschen auskennt, weiß, es gibt nicht,
die Antifa, das ist kein Dachverband, das ist keine Organisation, das ist keine GmbH, ne? Das ist einfach eine, eine Idee, der sich Menschen,
verbunden, fühlen oder eben nicht, aber es gibt nicht so etwas wie eine Angehörigkeit. Aber weil von der AfD ja regelmäßig äh solche absurden Verschwörungstheoren,
verbreitet werden, wie das es, dass Mitglieder der Antifa irgendwie was, was ich Demogeld bekämen, ist es ja jetzt ein ein wiederkehrendes Mehm, ähm.
Dass wir ja hier auch schon häufig gewürdigt haben, zuletzt mit diesem schönen äh Lied, ne? Ich habe einen Antifa-Tarifvertrag und,
Und in diesem Kontext hat sich dann auch, ich weiß, ich kann leider gerade gar nicht sagen, wo das seinen Ursprung genommen hat. Aber hat irgendjemand mal.
Quasi eine Antifa-Mitgliedskarte entworfen. Und vermutlich mit so einem.
Mit einem Kartendrucker, den man ja, also den, in unseren Kreisen viele Leute haben, sich auch eine gedruckt, ja? Und das ist eben die, der Antifa-Mitgliedsausweis, ja, Antifa Family Card oder sowas steht da drauf,
Ähm so und jetzt da wird dann immer wieder gescherzt, ne? Wenn irgendwo angefangen wird, ähm.
Über bezahlte Antifa-Demonstranten oder sowas zu reden, dann dann kursiert wieder dieses Bild so von solchen Karten, wurde gesagt, ey, vergesst nicht,
euch nachher das Demogeld abzuholen. Ich habe dieses noch noch fünf Demos und ich kriege extra Punkte zum zum Einkaufen im Bio Laden. Also der letzte Kit, das ist jetzt ein Mai, was weitergeht. Jetzt hat irgend so ein Kuh Anon Amerikaner.
Dieses Ding aufgegriffen und hat verbreitet jetzt das Bild der Deutschen Antifa Mitgliedskarte.
Und das ist jetzt sechzigtausendfach Rituited oder oder was auch immer, ja? Und natürlich gibt's dann einerseits die Leute, die eben
die ihn dann irgendwie solche Sachen sagen, wie hey das ist aber die alte Karte, die neuen sehen ja ganz anders aus und solche ne, die ihn da halt äh helfen in seinem Rebit zu verschwinden. Und dann gibt's halt auch viele, die sagen, Alter, du wirst hier gerade verarscht, ja? Und das.
Und jetzt kannst du dir diesen Typen angucken, der jetzt wiederum natürlich sich über die lustig macht, die ihm behaupten, die ihm sagen würden, er würde
er würde verarscht, wo äh wobei er doch hier ein ganz klares Beweisfoto dieser Karte hat und du fragst, also ich meine, dass, wenn du dich, wenn du dir solche Sachen anschaust, dann.
Mit Payback-Funktion. Es ist wirklich so großartig.
Alles, also das ist so, es ist so äh so großartig, ja, aber irgendwie machst du dir auch ja sorgen dann, ne.
Ja, ja, klar, ne? Ich sehe dich ja auch gerade so einen schönen Tret, wo auch einer so, ja, ne, und für alle Leute, die sagen, das wäre ja nur Fake und irgendwie, du bist ja blöd und so weiter, ne. Äh ja, nee, ich habe noch mehr Fotos bekommen von Leut.
Kannst du dir echt, ey, hier, Michael Beuten, heißt der gute M.
Äh neunter Juni, also unglaublich. Dann haben sie noch irgendwelche Checks von Job George. Soros äh getweetet und dann sagt ein anderer, ey neben dem Bitte runter, das ist meiner.
Ja ja, zitiert dann auch noch so ein paar andere Satirische Tweets hier.
Wunderbar.
Weil bei den Schwurblinden grad rumgeht, dass wir alle vom Staat bezahlt sein. Stimmt nicht ganz, die Antifa-Trink heute mal wieder die Kosten. Denkt bitte dran, euch kontaktlos zu Identifizieren und den Chorona Bonus anzukli,
Gradi aus.
Ich will ich denke, alles, was ich sagen möchte, ist diese Studie sicherlich ein sehr wichtiger ähm sehr wichtiger Beginn.
Und das heißt aber wie bei jeder Studie, äh sie ergründet nicht den vollumfangen, der zu erforschenden Wahrheit. Und ähm
ja. Wer, ich würde sagen, also da ist auch ganz klar jetzt auch kürzlich hier ähm
von der von der äh vom linksgrünen Zentralkomitee der Antifa auch nochmal Geld dafür ausgelobt worden für Studien, äh die sich das halt nochmal gen.
Genau, ich kann auch nur nochmal die Konklusion zitieren, ja, hier ist davon die Rede, einerseits, ja, kann.
Also ist,
Formulierung war äh die Ergebnisse deuten darauf hin, dass sie gegen Rede zu die Polarisierung der Diskussion beitrug und dass die vom RI organisierte Gegenrede weitere Gegenreden,
anregt, ja? Also, erstmal dieser Effekt, dass wir auch gerade beschrieben hast, so kann dadurch vor allem äh durch diese Anregung erfolgreich sein und weniger Phase erfüllte Reaktionen hervorgerufen, haben könnte.
Könnte es gibt Indizien, bewiesen es ja noch gar nichts.
Ich bin mal gespannt, was Alexander Kikolizilstudio sagt,
Wir kommen, wir kommen zu jetzt nur noch kurz, meldungen, also die, die wir nicht mehr in voller Tiefe äh besprechen. Hm.
Und zwar erreicht uns eine Meldung aus dem Ausnehmsdorf Görendorf.
Und es ist wirklich, sie haben uns ja hier schon darüber lustig gemacht, dass die deutsche Telekom, was ich also auch wirklich an Zynismus nichts überbieten finde, diesen wir jagen Funklöcher Wettbewerb gemacht hat.
Die haben ja quasi gesagt so.
Gemeinden können sich bei uns bewerben und dann wählen wir aus, wem wir das Funkloch stopfen. Ist das nicht toll? Ja? Und dann hat sich die Gemeinde nebendorf in Sachsen-Anhalt.
An dieser Ausschreibung beteiligt.
Und ein diese Gemeinde, ja, die ja sich immerhin in der Bundesrepublik Deutschland ähm befindet, hat einen kostenlosen Ausbau mit LTE gewonnen.
Bei der deutschen Telekom, die müssen noch nicht einmal dafür bezahlen, als der ich meine, selbstverständlich müssen, die dort.
Potenziell zu gewinnenden Kundinnen und Kunden dann für ihre Mobilfunkt,
Verträge bezahlen und es ist sowieso eine eine Formulierung, die ich sehr unterhaltsam finde, dass man ein kostenloses Ausbau mit LTE gewonnen hat, ja. Aber was noch, was noch absurder ist, als dass man einen kostenlosen Ausbau mit LTE gewinnt.
Ist, dass man den Preis ablehnt, denn.
Der Gemeinderat hat Ende Mai zwanzig zwanzig den Preis im deutschen Telekom-Wettbewerb. Wir jagen Funklöcher wegen möglicher Elektromagnetischer Strahlung mit unabsehbaren Folgen für die Gesundheit.
Oh Gott.
Unter anderem, weil sich die Sendeanlage ja unmittelbar im Ortskern befindet, wie von ihr selbst vorgeschlagen.
Alter. Das heißt, kein LTE.
Na ja, der Bürgermeister, das muss man jetzt auch noch sagen, der Bürgermeister hat einen anderen Grund dafür genannt, er sagte, die wollten uns nur einen Euro Miete für den Standort zahlen, dabei wissen wir, dass die Telekom im Nachbardorf zweitausend Euro zahlt.
Und man hätte der Telekom andere Standorte angeboten. Ey Leute.
Ey Leute, ihr habt halt nicht verdient, dann so und Thorsten Kleins ähm,
auch sicherlich vielen Hörerinnen bekannt, ein äh netzpolitischer Journalist oder überhaupt digital Journalist auch seit wahrscheinlich zwanzig Jahren mindestens ähm,
der twitterte dazu, dass absurde ist ja, je weiter dein Handy vom Funkmast weg ist, desto stärker funkt das ja auf der Suche danach, ne
also du willst echt eigentlich kein Handy in der Tasche haben, was die ganze Zeit nach dem Funken was sucht, weil der ballert da die ganze Zeit sich den Akku leer und sagt, ey, kann ich hier irgendwo was
empfangen. Und wenn du mal empfangen hast, dann muss es auf jeden Fall mit höchster Sendeleistung dahinfunken. Wenn du dir das Ding ans Ohr hältst, ne? Also.
Leute, das habt ihr äh das habt ihr nicht gut gemacht,
oder vielleicht habt ihr es auch gut gemacht. Also für die Grundstückspreise ist äh ist, sagen wir mal, eine Gentrification ist in näherer Zukunft in dem Ort auf jeden Fall nicht zu befürchten.
Wobei, vielleicht, vielleicht gibt's ja noch ein paar Impfgegner ausm Prenzlauer Berg, die gerne nach Nebensdorf Görendorf ziehen.
Ja, weil der Christian kein, kein Corona, weil gibt ja keinen fünf G.
Wer ist nur vier G.
Vier G. Nicht mal vier G.
Ja, genau, die hätten auch nur vier G gewonnen. Oh, Man.
Dann gibt es ein äh neues Gesetz aus dem Innenministerium.
Das herabgereicht wurde, denn das ist der Entwurf eines Gesetzes zur Stärkung der Sicherheit im Passausweis und ausländerrechtlichen Dokumentationswesen.
Nun ist die ähm Sicherheit von Reisepässen,
Personalausweisen, ja, eines meiner äh Interessen, meine per persönlichen Interessengebiete. Einerseits, was die darin verbauten SmartCards angeht. Ähm andererseits, was die Technologien der Prüfung angeht und auch, was die Biometrischen
Merkmale angeht. Ähm zu den Smartphones ist zu sagen, wer ist jetzt, ich fasse es mal kurz, da gibt es keine,
nennenswerten, Bekannten, Schwachstellen, also da sind äh gute Entscheidungen getroffen worden, die bis jetzt ganz gut gehalten haben, ne, also den den Smartkartei eines äh Personalausweises äh.
Zureplizieren ist nach meiner Kenntnis nicht
möglich. Es war allerdings so, dass die Prüfung der Ru Zertifikate lange Zeit nicht stattgefunden hat, auch das haben wir hier ähm in Lokbuchnetzpolitik berichtet. Ich glaube, es war in den USA oder was in Deutschland, also du konntest es war quasi eigentlich nicht möglich, ein.
Personalausweis zu äh zu klonen oder zu fälschen, aber weil die Signaturen nicht geprüft wurden,
an den Prüfgeräten, war das dann doch möglich. Aber okay, da erinnere ich mich nicht mehr ganz ähm Hinweise, freue ich mich in den Kommentaren. Wir haben's auf jeden Fall hier in der Sendung vor ein paar Jahren mal besprochen.
So, jetzt gibt es ähm die Situation Passfoto. So ähm.
Und es ist tatsächlich so, ich habe das ja auch mal, glaube ich, hier erzählt, dass ich mal bei so einer Veranstaltung war, der Sicherheitsdrucker. Also, das sind die, das ist die Branche, die.
Im Prinzip kunstvolle Druckverfahren entwickelt, in der Hoffnung.
Dass die Schwerfeldspar sind. Ja, was natürlich eigentlich lustig ist, weil wenn die sagen, wir haben einen Druckprozess entwickelt, den wir anbieten können, ist natürlich die Annahme, dass es jemand anders nicht könnte, schon durchaus,
ähm,
unterhaltsam, ne? Aber immerhin, damit sichern wir unser Bargeld ab, damit sichern wir unsere Pässe gegen Fälschung. Das ist tatsächlich so, ähm, das wird ja auch sehr gerne,
ähm zitiert von diesen Branchen und auch vom BKA und von äh Bundesdruckerei.
Man findet eigentlich keine gefälschten Pässe. Und das führt man zurück darauf, dass diese.
Äh Druckverfahren und die Papiere und das ist alles so aufwendig ist, dass es, dass der Pass quasi fälschungssicher ist, inklusive eben auch dem digitalen Teil und so weiter.
Was man aber durchaus findet, sind manipulierte Pässe und die gelten dann aber nicht als gefälscht. Ähm,
Also, ne, wenn wenn du jetzt ein, du hast quasi einen gültigen Pass und manipulierst den, dass in dem du hinten aufschneidest, ein anderes Bild reinmachst, ähm dann ist das kein gefälschter Pass in deren Statistik.
Sondern wird gar nicht gezählt oder was. Ach so.
Polierter Pass, aber der ist ja echt.
Manipulierter Pass. Okay, ne, muss man auch unterscheiden.
Und und ein Angriff, der seit seit ähm langer Zeit auch bekannt ist, ähm besteht eben darin, dass du ähm.
Gezielt ein Pass einen vollständig gültigen Pass anfertigen lässt mit einem gemorften Bild.
Und das geht folgendermaßen. Du,
möchtest also jetzt für eine, du hast eine Zielperson, für die möchtest du einen Pass ausstellen, ein Gefälschen. Ja, also im Zweifelsfall, also du möchtest dieser Person,
die Möglichkeit verschaffen mit einer bestimmten Staatsbürgerschaft zu reisen, ne? Das ist ja das, was du sagst, was ein paar ist. Äh, was ein Pass verschaffen ist. Jetzt hast du die Person. Und nun suchst du dir eine möglichst dieser Person
ähnlichsehende Person. Also ungefähr gleich groß, Haarfarbe und solche Sachen sollten stimmen, ja? Und jetzt sehen die natürlich immer noch.
Sehr unterschiedlich aus. Diese beiden Personen, ne.
Und jetzt nimmst du von beiden das biometrische Foto und morfst diese beiden Gesichter zu einem. Und zwar zu einem Gesicht, was,
fünfzig Prozent Ähnlichkeit zu der einen Person hat und fünfzig Prozent Ähnlichkeit zu der anderen Person.
Und mit diesem Bild in der Tasche geht dann eben die legitime Person zur Behörde, lässt sich einen neuen Pass ausstellen, gibt dieses Bild ab,
Und das Bild wird in der Regel akzeptiert, weil es der Person ähnlich genug sieht,
Und jetzt kriegst du dann nach so und zu viel Wochen oder tagen deinen Pass zurück und dieser gleiche Pass wird jetzt auch für die andere Person akzeptiert, weil das Bild, was in dem Pass ist, auch dieser Person ausreichend ähnlich sieht.
So, dass Verfahren.
Und ähm diese Angriffe finden statt. Das gibt es, also gibt's Anhaltspunkte für, dass das passiert. Und das Pang-Kollektiv hat auch vor, ich glaube.
Zwei oder drei Jahren, das mal ähm testweise gemacht, ja und haben dann auch eine Reise, glaube ich, äh,
oder ne, die haben das, die haben den Pass nicht zur Anwendung gebracht, die haben den nur herstellen lassen. Ich habe das damals, glaube ich, auch hier kritisiert, weil das Ergebnis von so etwas ist natürlich, dass es gesetzliche Verschärfungen gibt, die diese Form von.
Einbringen von manipulierten Passfotos unterbinden sollen. Und genau das passiert jetzt hier mit diesem Gesetzesentwurf und zu der Veröffentlichung ist aber wirklich, das ist auch wieder hier.
BMI Gold, ja. Der erste Satz.
Der technische Fortschritt im Bereich der digitalen Bildbearbeitung ermöglicht inzwischen das sogenannte.
Ich dachte so, Herr Himmel, jetzt können wir sogar schon Morphen, da sehr unglaublich, ne? Ich habe da mal geguckt, wann seit wann das Mophing gibt. Äh tatsächlich äh seit Anfang der neunziger Jahre.
Ähm war diese Technologie soweit, dass man ähm über Zeugende
also überzeigende Ergebnisse erzielen konnte. Äh Wikipedia nennt neunzehnhunderteinundneunzig den Film Blackow White von Michael Jackson, aber auch Terminatorverfilmungen
als äh Beispiele für Überzeugung der Anwendung der Moffing-Technologie.
Also das Musikvideo meinst du, ne? Von Michael Jackson.
Musikvideo. Äh habe ich Filme gesagt? Naja, es war auch okay, Musik.
Schon.
Und ähm also ja, ja, inzwischen wird diese Technologie, die technische Fortschritt ermöglicht, das inzwischen, das stimmt.
Für gegebene Werte von inzwischen, ja? Und ähm,
dann sagen sie weiter, lala lalala, wenn man das nämlich, wenn man jetzt zwei Gesichter Morf, dann kann nicht nur die Passinhaberin oder der Passinhaber, sondern unter Umständen auch eine dritte Person,
deren Gesichts zu dem Passbett erhalten sind, den Pass zum Grenzüberschritt nutzen. Jetzt eine dritte Besserung auch noch. Ich glaube, damit haben sie äh also.
Da muss ein Fehler sein, weil ich glaube, sie meinen ja eigentlich eine zweite Person, wäre ja schon schlimm genug, ne. Wenn wir jetzt noch eine dritte Person hätten, dann werden unsere Pässe, aber wirklich langsam Familienantifa-Familienausweis, ne.
Na gut, ich meine, ist die Frage, äh letztlich ist das ja die Frage, wie gut auch diese Gesichtserkennungssysteme ähm da funktionieren.
Danke, darauf will ich nämlich hinaus, denn ähm.
All das, was wir jetzt hier geschildert haben, habe ich jetzt mal so immer angenommen, ist bei einer menschlichen Kontrolle.
Die tatsächliche Schwachstelle ist aber in diesem Geldsystem, in den Gesichtserkennungssystem, weil die haben eine,
unglaublich schlechte Erkennungsrate für den Fall. Ähm also wenn du so ein Gesichtserkennungssystem hast, ne? Du kannst im Prinzip.
Das System nach zwei Hypothesen arbeiten lassen, wie immer. Und das ist im Prinzip, ne? Setzt der die Grundhypothese, der über Einstimmung.
Zugrunde und lässt sich nur dann nicht durch, wenn du.
Zu viel Nichtübereinstimmung hast? Oder hat er die Grundhypothese, der Nichtübereinstimmung und lässt sich nur dann durch, wenn du ausreichende Übereinstimmung hast.
Und diese Grenzkontrollsysteme sind so gebaut, dass sie die Grundhypothese der über Einstimmung haben. Das heißt, du kannst an vielen dieser biometrischen,
ähm Vergleichspunkte, die er da zum Einsatz kommen.
Kannst du an einem größeren Teil davon auch scheitern und der lässt dich trotzdem noch durch.
Und das ist das, was hier bei diesen, mit diesem Mophing eben auch ermöglicht wird. Nun ist das auf zweierlei Weisen interessant. A wenn da ein Mensch draufschaut,
ist die Erkennungsmöglichkeit dieses Menschen äh die sind auch limitiert. Wir haben da ähm vor,
vielen Jahren ähm habe ich an der ähm an der freien Universität Berlin ähm Seminare in Forenses Forensischer Psychiatrie besucht. Und da gab's ein sehr schönes Beispiel dafür.
Da wurden uns, hm, sagen wir mal zehn Fotos von Personen gezeigt.
Und wir sollten sagen, welches, welche dieser zehn Fotos die gleiche Person zeigen und welche nicht. Ja,
und das kannst du ja äh, kannst du auch mit fünf Fotos machen, ne? Kannst du also Personen, die du nicht kennst und du siehst von den Bildern und du sollst jetzt sagen, hier, auf dem, auf Bild A und Bild B, ist das die gleiche Person oder sind das unterschiedliche,
Und die Trefferquote, die Menschen dabei allein erzielen, sind katastrophal schlecht,
Ja, also solange das jetzt nicht 'ne Person ist, die du kennst, wenn du jetzt sagst, ach so, das ist eine Person, die ich kenne, dann erkennst du die Übereinstimmung natürlich ähm,
Also dann weißt du, das ist der Tim, das ist er nicht, ne? Aber wenn du jetzt, wenn wir, wenn ich jetzt ein Bild zeige, von zwei Personen, die dir unbekannt sind und die du nicht schon öfter gesehen hast, dann kannst du
wenn die ausreichend ähnlich sind, überhaupt nicht gut erkennen, ist das jetzt ein Bild von den du nicht. Und dieser Fall tritt ja auch ein, bei so einer Passkontrolle. Wenn da jetzt ein menschlich kontrolliert,
Ja, also ob da jetzt das Bild von dir auf deinem Pass kann, bis zu zehn Jahre alt sein, äh wenn es dir ausreichend ähnlich sieht, wird der äh kontrolleur, da der Fahrscheinkontrolle, im Zweifelsfall sagen, alles klar, kannst durch, oder nicht, ne? Wahrscheinlich am Ende auf deine Hautfarbe an.
Und ähm.
Ja und äh oft sind ja auch die Fotos sehr alt und äh viele Jahre dazwischen und sie ist mittlerweile ganz anders aus. Und damals war ich ja noch kein Hippie irgendwie. Jetzt habe ich.
Und das soll halt, das soll halt, das soll halt natürlich diese diese biometrischen Systeme eigentlich verbessern, aber deren Erkennungsrate ist selbst, es ist unter Realbedingungen eben so katastrophal, dass sie, dass die die Dinger halt so so,
ähm nachlässig getunet haben, dass du eben mit so einem Photomope tatsächlich zwei Gesichter dadurch kriegst.
Tja, ähm wie reagiert äh der Gesetzgeber, ähm, ja, die sagen, also jetzt, die Dienst, also sie, sie sagen, es gibt nur noch elektronische Übermittlungen.
Und im am liebsten ist ihnen eigentlich das Bild wird vor Ort gemacht. Ja, also du gehst als Person dahin und kannst jetzt nicht irgendwie so ein Bild von der Fotografin mitbringen.
Sondern du musst dich dahin stellen und die äh Sachbearbeiterin am Amt macht das Bild jetzt von dir, um sicherzustellen, dass quasi die Person die da ist und so weiter, ne?
Äh kannst natürlich jetzt auch einfach eine andere Person hinschicken, aber äh den Tipp gebe ich, äh gebe ich denen nicht. Ähm.
Jetzt äh dann haben die Fotografen und Fotografin,
protestiert und haben gesagt, ey, ne, biometrisch, korrekte Bilder anzufertigen, ist eigentlich ein ganz gutes Business für uns. Und dann hat das BMW gesagt, ja alles klar, euren Problemen äh tragen wir in so Fernsorge. Wir machen jetzt äh wir richten euch eine gesicherte, elektronische Übermittlung ein,
wofür ihr euch vorher registrieren müsst und der macht es dann möglich nach etwaigen Manipulationen des Lichtbilds auch zu einem späteren Zeitpunkt nachzuverfolgen
äh wer die manipulation angefertigt hat. Mit anderen Worten, die Fotografen, Studios, Fotografiestudios, kriegen jetzt,
so digitale Zertifikate, die es ihnen ermöglichen, dort Bilder,
hinzuschicken und sie müssen aber gleichzeitig quasi dann dafür bürgen, dass diese Bilder nicht von ihnen manipuliert wurden. Ja.
Super. Also die nächste Sp.
Und jetzt hast du eine voll digitale Verarbeitung,
die, ja, und jetzt frage ich mich, die, äh, was machen die äh digitale äh biometrische Fotoboxbetreiberinnen und Betreiber
die am Bürger anstehen, ne? Und für für schmalen Taler von irgendwie sechzehn Euro oder was, dir irgendwie so ein total beschissenes Automatenbild geben. Na ja, also da gibt's jetzt eine Anpassung.
Ja ich ich tue mich da schwer mit, dass jetzt unbedingt zu kritisieren, dass sich, dass man sich natürlich um die,
Sicherheit der Ausweisdokumente Gedanken macht. Ähm aber die Konsequenzen, digitale Übermittlungen,
gehen natürlich auch alle in die Richtung, dass du natürlich dann sehr viel hochqualitativere
biometrische Bilder bei den Behörden hast und uns war ein zentraler Stelle, das ist ja der Teil der selten besprochen wird selten kritisiert wurde, wo sich eigentlich nur wir damals als CC.
Bei der letzten Personalausweisgesetznovelle gegen gewendet haben. Das ist nämlich hier diese Zentrale ähm.
Bilddatenbank Erfassung gibt.
Die ähm für für diese Bilder eben gilt. Und die ja dann wiederum bei flächendeckender Kameraüberwachung oder Gesichtserkennung ähm entsprechende.
Probleme machen kann.
Ja, okay.
Das ist also etwas, was auch passiert und äh ja.
Wer äh wer das nicht möchte, kann sich ja zumindest nochmal zehn Jahre Pass mit einem schönen Automatenfoto äh sichern, in dem er oder sie.
Nochmal schnell einen neuen Pass holt. Der Gesetzentwurf wird nämlich jetzt äh nochmal in den Bundestag zur Beratung und Verabschiedung gegeben, also der genau das ist ja immer,
Unser Gesetzgebungsprozess funktioniert ja so, dass die Regierung die Gesetze schreibt und einmal durch den Bundestag reichen muss. Etwas, was ich ja relativ häufig schon kritisiert habe.
Ein anderes Thema, was wir, glaube ich, was in diesem Land unterberichtet ist und viel zu wenig skandalisiert wird. Wir reden ja so relativ viel darüber.
Ähm was zum Beispiel Regierungsmitglieder in den USA für begehen.
Also Behinderung der Justiz, der Aufklärung.
Potenziell ihrer Verbrechen oder deren anderer, die für sie begangen wurden? Ähm und.
In Deutschland diskutieren wir bei weitem nicht so viel darüber, dass.
Ähm im Untersuchungsausschuss maut, der sich ja um an die Scheuer kümmert und auch im Untersuchungsausschuss Berater Affäre, der sich um Ursula von der Laien kümmert. Beide.
Ähm.
Von ihren Handys, Daten gelöscht hatten. Die, der Untersuchungsausschuss gerne gesehen hätte, zur Aufklärung der schwerwiegenden Verdachtsmomente, was die Integrität dieser.
Personen und ihrer Handlung in diesem Kontext angeht. Ja und ne,
Andi Scheuer, oh shit, die wollen mein Handy, nee, alles klar, einmal alles löschen, ja? Und da äh haben jetzt dann eben die,
Leiter der jeweiligen Untersuchungsausschüsse, das ist im Untersuchungsausschuss Maut der Udo Schiefnäher und im Untersuchungsausschuss Beraterfähre der Wolfgang Helmich äh sich mal langsam in die Richtung bewegt zu sagen, na ja, das wäre schon ganz gut.
Wenn Ministerin und Minister ihre.
Die Daten von ihren Diensthandys nicht löschen dürften, beziehungsweise wir sicherstellen, dass sie auf geeignete Weise archiviert werden. Ähm und Schäuble, ähm der, ja, der.
Präsident des Bundestags ist.
Ja, Parlamentspräsident.
Parlamentspräsident. Ähm sagt eben auch, dass die möglicherweise unzureichende Dokumentation der elektronischen Dokumente.
Dokumentation von Regierungshandeln
äh berührt ist und ein wesentlicher Aspekt der parlamentarischen Kontrolle der Exekutive darstellt. Ja, also es könnte sehr gut sein, dass hier dass wir hier eben eine Speicherpflicht für diese Geräte, die von den Ministerinnen und Ministern verwendet werden bekommen. Zum Zwecke der parlamentarischen Kontrolle.
Halte ich jetzt erstmal ähm ich meine, wenn wir hier zwei ähm intensiv Täter haben,
die Spuren vernichtet haben, dann denke ich, ist das vielleicht auch mal äh geboten, wohl bemerkt,
in dem Kontext, dass es sich hier um Ministerinnen und Minister handelt, die nun wirklich nichts zu verbergen
haben sollten, im Gegensatz zu Bürgerinnen und Bürgern, bevor ich jetzt schon wieder in den Kommentaren Leute lese, Linus, du bist gegen Vorratsdatenspeicherung, aber bei Regierungen äh Regierungsmitgliedern auf einmal nicht. Nee, genau, da,
bin ich nicht dagegen, weil die ganze Idee ähm des Datenschutzes und der des Schutzes vor Überwachung ist ja bekanntermaßen
dass wir eine transparenten Staat haben wollen und die Privatsphäre als Abwehrrecht der Bürgerinnen und Bürger,
äh gegenüber dem Mächtigen Staat.
Die Maschinen lesbare Regierung, die klassische Forderung. Mhm.
Ich möchte, dass Andy Scheuers Handy Maschine lesbar ist. Ja, dass er keine Beweise vernichten kann.
Der Vorratsdatenspeicherung. Warum nicht.
Zur Sicherheit. Für die Sicherheit.
Ja, das äh da ist so, haben wir doch jetzt die ganzen Jahre immer gehört, dass es einfach auch wichtig ist.
Für die Sicherheit ist es.
Einfach man kann sonst einfach auch gar keine ordentliche Ermittlungsarbeit mehr machen.
Du äh Tim, ich bin ganz ehrlich, weißt du, warum ich das gerne hätte? Äh Vorratszeitenspeicherung von Missministerial Mobiltelefon? Ähm wegen Terrorismus und Kinderpornografie hätte ich das gerne.
Oh ja, das ist natürlich ein großes Problem. Da da muss auch damit einfach nicht genug getan.
Oh, äh, ach, Misser jetzt, pass auf, wir haben dieses, wir haben wirklich dieses Thema nicht behandelt, der Fall in Münster. Äh Scheiße, das wäre eigentlich ein Thema gewesen, was wir auch halten in die Sendung aufnehmen sollen.
Der Fall in Münster.
Ja, in Münster wurde ein ähm also ein äh eine.
Wie nennt man sowas ja also wirklich ein dickes, dickes Ding. Ja, also ganz ekelhafter Fall und eben äh unter anderem hat der.
Einer der Beschuldigten, es sind ja mehrere und ganz fürchterlicher Fall, der hat unter anderem wohl eine signifikante Serverfarm irgendwie betrieben. Ähm vielleicht nehmen wir das in den in die nächste Sendung nochmal mit auf, weil da ist der Polizei mal wieder,
ein ähm.
Schlag gegen die Kriminalität gelungen und hier auch in einem echt ekelhaften Aktiven Fall, ne? Also das ging da glaube ich um den, wenn ich das richtig erinnere, um den Stiefsohn.
Ähm.
Da ist gerade der Polizei ein Ermittlungserfolg gelungen, der wirklich wieder fürchterliches zu Tage befördert hat. Das sei dann hier wenigstens angemerkt, dass wir das zur Kenntnis genommen haben und ich hab's verpennt, das wird hier die Sendung aufzunehmen.
Letzte Meldung, es gab jetzt auch relativ viele Fragen, was denn wohl mit dem Congress dieses Jahr ist.
Dem Chaos Conny Kirschenkongress, das CC.
Chaos Communication Congress, dem siebenunddreißig C drei äh und wir äh haben dazu.
Im Prinzip wir haben die den großen Luxus.
Dass wir erst sehr spät entscheiden müssen, ob diese Veranstaltung stattfindet oder nicht. Und das liegt daran, dass wir das ja vollständig in ehrenamtlicher Arbeit.
Organisieren, ja? Es gibt natürlich die ein oder andere ähm Arbeit, für die wir Dienstleister in Anspruch nehmen,
aber wir unterhalten ja kein Mitarbeiterstamm, den wir jetzt entlassen müssten, wenn die Veranstaltung nicht stattfindet oder äh sonstige Dinge. Das heißt, unser ist eigentlich so,
Ende September, Anfang Oktober, wo wir die Entscheidung treffen müssen, machen wir das jetzt oder nicht.
Bei anderen Veranstalterinnen und Veranstaltern ist der ist ein solcher sehr viel früher,
ne, weil Investitionen getätigt werden müssen und so weiter. Oder auch Geld eingenommen werden muss und so. Und äh dazu haben wir jetzt ein Blogpost geschrieben, in dem ich zitiere
ersteht. Aktuell ist es nicht abschätzbar, ob und welcher Form ein siebenunddreißig C drei in diesem Jahr durchführbar ist
Selbst wenn es uns rechtlich möglich werden sollte, ist es ja aktuell nach aktuellem Stand nicht, wissen wir um die besondere Verantwortung unseren Teilnehmenden gegenüber, um dieser Verantwortung gerecht zu werden
wird insbesondere unserer Zerrt, das äh Chaos Emergency Respons Team, also das Team, was sich um.
Ähm feuer, polizeiliche Angelegenheiten und insbesondere die medizinische Versorgung der Teilnehmenden kümmert. Maßgeblich bei der Bewertung der Situation einbezogen.
Wir rechnen damit, dass die Lage spätestens im Oktober klar genug sein wird, um sinnvoll bewerten zu können, ob der siebenunddreißig C drei als Präsenzveranstaltung stattfinden kann
Das bedeutet ausdrücklich, dass wir uns alle Optionen offen halten müssen
inklusive eines siebenunddreißig C drei erst im nächsten Jahr. Sobald es eine endgültige Entscheidung gibt, wird diese hier in diesem Blog veröffentlicht und,
was auch in diesem Beitrag steht, ist wenn ein siebenunddreißig C drei als Präsenzveranstaltung stattfindet, dann in Leipzig.
Denke, leuchtet ein, aber ähm da.
Sich viele Leute eben darüber Sorgen machen und wahrscheinlich viele Leute auch nicht wussten, wie viele Freiheitsgrade. Wir haben äh die finale Entscheidung.
Ähm noch in die Zukunft zu schieben. Ähm war das schon sinnvoll, dass dieser Blogpost dann mal veröffentlicht wurde, für alle interessieren.
Ja. Auf jeden Fall. Das war's, oder?
Ich könnte ach so, ah, da habe ich gerade am Anfang, also zum Thema Anti zum Thema Diskriminierung und ähm.
Polizeigewalt gibt's übrigens zwei Folgen. Äh Lockbuch Freiheit. Die wollte ich eigentlich nur empfehlen, ja. Die acht zum Berliner Anti-Diskriminierungsgesetz, Lokbuchfreiheit,
null null acht und die Lokofreiheit null null drei Polizeigewalt und Rasial Profiling. Äh was ich da ganz interessant finde, ist, dass wir eben diese Polizeigewalt und Race Rasial Profiling ähm schon vor einigen Wochen gemacht haben, also,
zeigt, dass das eben ein Thema ist, dass äh uns in in dieser Podcast und YouTube Serie.
Und eben auch die Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte nicht erst seit gestern. Interessiert, Lokbuchfreiheit, äh wie gesagt, der YouTube-Kanal, den ich mit.
Lea Beckmann zusammen mache. Ähm wir freuen uns da über äh Likes, hab Scribes, Glückchen, Sternchen und Empfehlungen, denn ähm ich habe jetzt festgestellt, was ja äh was wir.
Selten machen, aber ich denke, wenn ihr uns anderen, wenn ihr unseren Podcast gut findet.
Dann freuen wir uns, sowohl beim Lokbuch Netzwerk, als auch beim Lokbuchfreiheit. Wenn ihr das Leuten empfehlt, für die die Sendung ebenfalls interessant sein könnte.
Mache ich ja hier auch. Mit Lokofreiheit.
Du bist schon so voll im YouTube-Modus, man kriegt dich gar nicht mehr eingefangen.
Nee, ich muss echt sagen, ähm dass er so als Zwischenfazit, also ich ähm.
Ich, also ich bin da, glaube ich, nicht besonders im YouTube-Modus und ich sehe, ich gucke, dass ich sehe, dass den anderen YouTube-Videos, welche, was da so die Stilmittel sind, die man in so einem YouTube-Video machen muss. Und diese mehr irgendwie zu anstrengend.
Mein Reden. Ja, naja, also es ist, muss halt jeder für sich selber abwägen und es gibt durchaus Inhalte, die die davon natürlich profitieren können und so.
Aber ja, meine positive Grundeinstellung zum Podcast ist äh unverändert.
Ähm UKW wollen wir wahrscheinlich auch nochmal kurz empfehlen, ne?
Das, das kannst du natürlich gerne tun. Empfehl doch mal UKW.
UKW, unsere kleine Welt,
der Podcast von Tim, den der sich da irgendwann mal eigentlich vor Jahren schon als kleine Resterampe installiert hat und der jetzt in,
letzter Zeit. Na ja, war doch so, also du hast den ja so ein bisschen als äh
da sind angelegt und dann aber einmal mit dem John ja diese Brexit.
Saga, aufgegriffen und jetzt mit Pavelmeyer diese äh Corona Saga und ist doch beides mit mit großen Ergebnissen und ähm ein guter Beitrag und äh ich würde ja vermuten,
ja, dass bei UKW die Corona Tracing App auch noch meine Würdigung erfährt.
Das durchaus vorstellbar, durchaus vorstellbar. Ja, dem kann ich gar nicht äh viel mehr hinzufügen. Das äh hast du schon gesagt. Restramper.
Ne? So bin ich.
Timis Restauramper.
Ja, es ist ein Talentschuppen, weißt du?
Dennis Talentschu.
Gut, jetzt haben wir unsere zwei Stunden hier auch äh beisammen. Ich würde sagen, für heute machen wir hier mal Klappe zu. Hast du noch Dankeschöns zu verteilen?
Ja, ein besonderes Dank äh ein besonderes Dankeschön habe ich äh für Felix.
Und ich habe dann noch weitere weiteren Dank äh für,
zwei unbekannte Personen, wie gesagt, mein Hinweis ist ja immer, wenn ich, wenn ihr euren Namen hier erwartet und ich von unbekannten Personen spreche, dann meldet euch bitte bei mir.
Und.
Vermutlich äh aber da das eigentlich kaum passiert, gehe ich davon aus, dass es dann äh anonyme Leute sind, die sich das auch so auf so zum Ziel gesetzt haben. Aber ich erwähne, dass dann hier trotzdem als Dank äh ist angekommen.
Und äh Robert ist herzlich gedankt.
Genau, mir bleibt dann nur äh wieder übrig allen anderen,
vor allem den Spendern zu danken, die äh regelmäßig beitragen in kleineren und manchmal auch in größeren Beträgen, das hilft alles sehr
und ja, insofern entlassen wir euch in die Woche, in die KW vierundzwanzig oder wann auch immer ihr das jetzt hört und äh.
Die nächste Woche. Jetzt muss es tschüss sagen. Ciao.
Ja, tschau, tschau.
Aux